at any given time people belong to
intersection groups of Civil Society
actors that they can feel that even
though maybe the president wasn't yet
directly elected that didn't happen
until uh 96 but throughout the 70s and
80s more and more room gets opened by
the Civil Society actors so to counter
the pessimistic polarization or
manufactur polarization the easiest way
is just to get organized and just trust
each other even on a small scale thank
you
all right thank you so much for the
great questions live long and prospering
thank
you thank you Audrey thank you Audrey
amazing
talk
okay with this we actually are
concluding the programming for this main
stage uh at this point the stage will be
closing down it will actually be
dividing into three stages which reopen
in the afternoon for more programming uh
starting in 24 minutes are more talks in
other stages uh around here on the same
level so you have talks around uh yeah
introduction to multilateral Trade
Credit set off an MPC onchain Capital
allocation Workshop what's going on in
into the Petra upgrade by Christine and
bridging trafi and defi through ethereum
and evm a pathway to Innovation so check
out those talks in those other stages
we'll need everyone to clear out of this
stage so we can reset uh and thank you
all for joining us here this morning
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
for
I
[Music]
oh
hello and welcome to stage three this is
the opening session of stage three so
you're very welcome on the opening day
of Devcon uh I think I don't know about
you but for me it has been quite
overwhelming this morning it's amazing
to see everything that's been put
together and I've noticed I think
already that there are two camps of
people at Devcon the people who are here
at some uh pop-up City before who were
like adjusted to time zones and things
like this and the people who arrived you
know over the weekend and yesterday and
still suffering from jetl so I don't
know you can tell by the room who who's
who but yes I will be here all day with
you for the afternoon so welcome to
stage three a little bit of housekeeping
first um if you want some bathrooms go
out to the right um you know those ER
your phones keep up on silent just to
respect the speakers we would love
people to take pictures everyone's
welcome to take pictures but please try
to keep the flash off so you don't uh
distract any speakers along the way
something super important um we will
have some QR codes up on the screen
while the speakers are talking and it
would be great if you scan them so that
you get access to this session and you
can type in your questions in there so
if you have questions that you want to
ask the speakers um I will come and ask
the questions on your behalf at the end
of the talk um so yeah scan the QR codes
are in the Devcon app you can um just
click into this session scroll down to
the end and you can already start typing
in your questions so that's a little a
little bit of housekeeping oper so for
the first session we have uh Kevin auki
so I guess I think it's probably one of
the most prominent names in all of um
the blockchain world never mind just
ethereum and he will talk to us about uh
onchain financing and governance not
governance unchain financing so I think
it's also kind of the industry is
becoming well enough established now
that a lot of us in the room have
already kind of felt maybe some of the
Pains of financing and paying with
crypto and organizing things like this
so yeah I think there's no one better to
actually give us a bit of an overview of
what has happened in the past and what
is coming up in the future so if you
will join me in welcoming Kevin auki to
the stage
[Applause]
[Music]
please hello everyone how are
you it's Devon hello everyone how are
you
thank you all right uh I'm opening up
this stage so I think we got to bring a
little bit of
energy my talk today is entitled onchain
Capital allocation that sounds like a
mouthful but what I'm going to talk
about is how do we distribute resources
or funding in order to meet our shared
needs from making a profit to making an
impact and how do we do that on
chain we're going to talk a little bit
about who I who I am and why I'm
qualified to talk about this space then
we'll talk about the design space and
then I want to talk a little bit about
uh a capital allocation protocol that
getcoin is working working on called Alo
protocol so uh let's get into it over
the last 22 quarterly rounds gitcoin of
which I am a co-founder has supported
the funding of public goods enabling
communities to fund their shared needs
we've funded $65 Million worth of
funding through 5 million unique
donations mostly through quadratic
funding is anyone in the audience a
getcoin
donor all right half the hands going up
amazing in 2020 my hero vitalic buin
called getcoin grants a significant
pillar of the ethereum ecosystem because
so many projects were relying on it for
some or all of their support and now we
are taking gitcoin from working for the
ethereum ecosystem to now working for
any evm based community so basically we
think that grants equals growth for your
community and we're taking what worked
for the ethereum ecosystem and making it
available to any layer 2 defi project NF
NF Community uh in the evm ecosystem and
enabling them to have the same type of
growth and resilience that getcoin has
brought to the ethereum
ecosystem so we've allocated $65 Million
worth of capital as of 2024 over the
last seven years and I think that that's
what makes me qualified to talk about
the design space of onchain capital
allocation I recently written a book
about onchain Capital allocation which
I'm releasing at Devcon this is a
approachable gu guide to funding what
matters in your ecosystem and I think
it's my opportunity and my pleasure to
cartography this design space and make
it comprehensible to people in the
ethereum ecosystem who are building the
next batch of funding infrastructure so
that we can find better ways to fund
what matters and that's what this talk
is about so onchain Capital allocation
is about onchain ways to finding for to
how we spend money so anytime you're
paying a bill you're Buy buying a coffee
you're flying to Bangkok you're
allocating Capital but at scale as you
start to deploy more and more capital
capital allocation becomes a full-time
job and it becomes a multiplayer game
for you and the people around you to try
to figure out how to reach your goals
together so at scale things like
Regional Government funding or Venture
Capital are capital allocation and
they're not only full-time jobs for the
people that are doing them but they're
existential for the communities that
they serve whether or not you fund a
project in your ecosystem whether your
ecosystem is a physical ecosystem like a
city or your defi ecosystem can be
existential to the communities that are
served there and so this is a really
important design space because we want
to make sure that we're making the right
decisions about funding our shared needs
and I think blockchains have a lot to
bring to the capital allocation design
space Legacy Capital allocation suffers
from gatekeeping and it's not precise
and it's not scalable so you think about
Robert Moses the power broker or anyone
that's deploying capital in a city or in
a digital Community they sort of become
a Power broker for these ecosystems
because people are coming to them
looking for money it changes the
relationship and it ints the power from
the people to the people who actually
have the capital and the people in these
Ivory Towers and in these cities City
Halls don't know how to deploy capital
in a way that helps people because
they're in their ivory tower that are
not in the streets engaging in the
everyday experience of being a citizen
in these communities we also see that
rfps and grants and investments in these
ecosystems can be mirrored in
bureaucracy if anyone's everever gone
through a Grant application process in
an NGO you know how painful the process
can be pages and pages of paperwork that
doesn't actually match what is actually
going on in the ecosystem creates a lot
of administrative overhead and at worst
some of these NOS in Grant giving
organizations become the mission
themselves instead of the mission being
the mission and I think that this is a
really suboptimal way to build an
ecosystem but luckily now we've got
blockchains and we can program our
values into our money at scale and so I
think that onchain Capital allocation is
going to be accessible meaning that
anyone who has a cell phone or an
internet connection can access onchain
Capital allocation it's going to be
transparent because of the inherent
transparent nature of
blockchains okay so um the uh really
cool thing about blockchains is that uh
I have the same access to the state that
the state of the blockchain that someone
like drone pow has access to um they can
be Democratic which means that we can
fund what matters to Everyday members of
these communities on the basis of what
the medians citizen once and we can do
it precisely at scale because we're
building Capital allocation into these
blockchainbased
ecosystems and and we can do it at scale
so there's no longer the bottleneck of a
central Grant administrator that we have
to deal with they can be Incorruptible
at the base layer because of the way
blockchains verify truth every block at
the base layer of these systems that we
can be sure that this shared truth that
we're looking at is the same for
everyone of the participants and they
can be evolutionary one of the coolest
things I think about gitcoin grants in
our history over the last six or seven
years is that every gitcoin Grant round
Builds on the last one we go through
this iterative development Loop where we
have a grant round and then we learn
from what from it and then we design a
next Grant round that hopefully
accommodates all of the learnings that
we had from the previous Grant
round why does Capital allocation matter
I think we're building a stack for a new
Financial system in this space a Staker
and other stakers that are running the
ethereum nodes are building the ethereum
network which is a set of shared State
upon which we can deploy a smart
contract and that smart contract we can
program our values into our money we can
build economies that are more
coordinated than they ever have been
before on top of that in 2017 there was
a wave of tokenization and we have
tokenized assets to the tunes of and
hundreds of billions of dollars of
capital and I think that you've now got
Central bankers and traditional Finance
years on CNBC talking about how we're
going to tokenize the entire economy
that seems really really cool to me and
what I want you to see after this talk
is what we're building on top of this
shared infrastructure the top half of
the stack is about how do we build a
political economy that supports human
coordination the solving of coordination
failures and ultimately collect action
in a 21st century Network driven way
okay so Capital allocation the layer of
the stack in which we're funding what
matters to each other is how we're going
to solve coordination failures and do
Collective action in the 21st century
coordination failures are just a term
for Anytime there's a group of humans
who want to create an outcome X and
they're not able to create that outcome
X because of their inability to
coordinate their shared resources that's
a coordination failure and it goes from
everything in your local from things in
your local community to Global examples
so things in your local community might
be how do we fund our our infrastructure
our transportation networks how do we
fund our parks to Global 21st century
problems like Rising authoritarianism or
climate change those are all
coordination failures so we can solve
these things with better Capital
allocation and I'm going to give a
couple examples of how we do that over
the next couple slides so getcoin itself
is known mostly for quadratic funding
that is one Capital allocation mechanism
that we have deployed and it's a
mechanism invented by vitalic buer and
Glenn W and Zoe hitzig and the the way
that this mechanism works is that we
reward contributors based off of the
number of contributions to their
projects not the amount that they have
funded to each project so you set out a
matching pool you'll allow grants to
apply to be a part of a matching
campaign and then the contributions to
those grants will be matched by the
centralized matching pool on the basis
of the breadth of cont contributions to
those grants as opposed to the death
okay so we're programming our values
into our money and we're optimizing for
the preferences of the poor and the many
over the rich and the few because we are
now matching each Grant on the basis of
the number of contributors to their
project not how much was given to them
so uh a really simple math like without
any math example of this is that uh if
if you have a grant that has $100 from
100 contributors and I have a grant that
has $100 from one contributor and we're
both in a quadratic funding Campaign
together you will get 99% of the
matching pool okay so the culture that
this enables in the communities that are
served by quadratic funding is a more
democratic culture where the preferences
of the body politic are represented in
the capital allocation decisions as
opposed to what ESS power broker would
want another mechanism that's been
gaining a lot of traction over the last
couple years is retroactive funding
popularized by vitalic buan and the
optimism ecosystem retroactive funding
is based on the idea that it's easier to
reward public goods and other other uh
projects that are good for your
community on the basis of hindsight
hindsight is 2020 it's easier to see if
something was good with the benefit of
hindsight than it would be to speculate
on whether it's going to be good in the
future and so what I think is really
neat about this is that it creates more
assertive and decisive funding decisions
about what we should be building into
these ecosystems and yes there's a
trade-off there in that you don't get uh
money when you're first starting out but
someone could build proactive funding
mechanisms on the basis of future
retroactive rewards and I think that
that's a really cool thing about the
modular software architecture of the
ethereum ecosystem system you can build
uh an add-on to this system that
proactively funds things maybe with like
say a prediction Market that uh is
expecting future retroactive rewards so
the culture that I think that this
really creates in these ecosystems is a
culture of karma where if I think that
I'm going to be able to do good for an
ecosystem and I know that there's going
to be retroactive rewards for that later
I can make the investment now on the
Assumption of a future retroactive
award another mechanism that's really
taking off in the ethereum ecosystem and
I just want to celebrate is the protocol
Guild which is a registry of execution
layer and consensus layer clients that
support the very infrastructure that we
rely on in order to run ethereum on our
hom staking devices and we rely on in
order to clear transactions in the
ethereum network it's a registry of
about
180 execution layer and consensus layer
developers who are able to contribute to
the foundation of the network and they
curate the registry themselves so
basically they make additions and
subtractions from the registry in order
to keep a aggregation of who's doing
this important work at the base layer of
the ethereum network and this makes it
very easy for Dows and evm based
projects to fund the infrastructure upon
which they rely uh protocol Guild in
2023 was able to raise $100 million to
support protocol developers in the
ethereum ecosystem and I think that this
is kind of like a 21st century native
example of what collective bargaining
looks like it's an aggregation of supply
and demand for talent and and uh and
funding of talent in the 21st century so
these are a couple examples I don't have
time to go through all of them of
different onchain Capital allocation
mechanisms that are growing in the
infinite Garden that is ethereum and one
of the things I think that's really cool
about this is the fundamental plurality
of these mechanisms in that they're all
compatible with each other your
ecosystem can run protocol Guild
retroactive funding and quadratic
funding and we can program our values
into our money create a culture that is
supported by these
institutions and I think that these
things are fundamentally compatible with
each other in that they do complimentary
things in these
ecosystems uh quadratic funding is
really good at creating a democratic
culture retroactive funding is really
good at creating a culture of Karma and
protocol Guild is really good at
supporting the infrastructure upon which
we all rely and so I think that this
philosophy that we've got at the Bas
layer of the ethereum network of client
diversity where we've got many different
clients that are supporting the ethereum
network could be supported and and
extended at the higher levels of the
ethereum ecosystem and we can have a
philosophy of practical pluralis ISM
where these things all work together in
order to create a culture that we're
really excited about and that uh and
that supports public goods in such a way
that's antifragile it's fundamentally
plural if one of these things goes away
uh or one implementation of it goes away
then we still are able to fund our
public goods and to fund our shared
needs so that's the design space of
onchain capital allocation and hopefully
you've seen some of these mechanisms out
in the wild either on getcoin or on
optimism or in the ethereum ecosystem
and I want to talk about the future of
the design space for the next 5 minutes
of my talk and how gitcoin is moving to
a multi mechanism future and enabling
more and more people to do Capital
allocation in their ecosystems with Alo
protocol which is our new mechanism
toolbox for software developers who are
able to deploy uh mechanisms into these
ecosystems so basically gitcoin is known
for quadratic funding and we're moving
to a multi mechanism future in which
we're going to support A diversity of
capital allocation mechanisms in our
getcoin grants program for our clients
and customers and to developers at large
so we believe in a plurality of
different funding mechanisms for the
ecosystem and we're releasing at Devcon
this year Alo protocol 2.1 which is a
suite of different modules that you can
use to fund what matters in your
ecosystem and each module is
individually containing well documented
Fork ready audited code with Crystal
Clear documentation that allows you to
assemble a capital allocation mechanism
for your ecos system that meets your own
needs so the core components of these of
Alo protocol is the registry which is a
registry of different projects in your
ecosystem that could be funded either
for impact or for profit okay so
getcoins not just for impact anymore
we're actually working with a couple
investment DS on how to they get up side
in their ecosystem Alo strategy which is
kind of like the brains of Alo protocol
it's an opinionated way of funding what
matters in your ecosystem and then aloc
kit which is a tool that allows you to
launch a web app on top of these think
of it as like a gitcoin grants clone in
less than a couple
minutes okay so that's Alo protocol and
we really see the future of this design
space being a plurality of different
Capital allocation mechanisms and we
want to build for the plurality and spin
the design space faster than we've ever
done before by making it easier and
faster for people to invent the next
gitcoin in this next Market cycle so you
can think of Alo protocol as a circuit
that takes in tokens and data and spits
out an opinionated distribution of those
tokens to different recipients in that
ecosystem what Taiwan semiconductor did
for Semiconductor and Chip manufacturing
we want to do for onchain Capital
allocation so instead of etching into
silicon a circuit for moving information
we're etching into the hardness of
ethereum a circuit that allows you to
allocate Capital within your ecosystem
in a fundamentally 21st century native
way we want to build aloe into the
protocol for doing Capital allocation so
the core components here are tokens made
possible by erc20 and then the data
layer made possible by the aloe registry
but we also support other registries out
there the strategy layer which is the
brains of the operation decides how to
route the tokens from an allocation
perspective but also from a distribution
perspective we make it easy to
distribute across a Merkel distribution
strategy a superf fluid drips sabler
cross L2 uh modules are all things that
we have planned on the road map and so
this modular nature really makes it easy
to sweep the design space of capital
allocation by subbing out modules
according to your own needs so erc20
makes it really sub easy to substitute
out different tokens the Alo registry is
abstracted in such a way that you can
abstract out uh sorry you can substitute
in different Registries the strategy
layer makes it really easy to substitute
different funding structures for your
ecosystem whether that's quadratic
funding retroactive funding conviction
voting or any other funding strategy
that you can that you can dream dream of
in your ecosystem and so it's this
modular architecture that I think is
really going to allow us to explore the
plurality of the capital allocation
design space on chain and to build what
we need as an infrastructure to fund
what matters in the 21st century whether
your project is an onchain project or if
you're a city state that's just trying
to fund better roads hospitals uh and
other things in your ecosystem so I'm
really excited about the different
permutation of ways that we could
combine these modules spin the design
space faster of funding what matters to
Everyday People in addition to the
people who are building the
infrastructure themselves and I Envision
a future in which we're going to build a
capital allocation system that serves
the needs of humanity as we move into
the 21st century and that's what we're
moving towards at gcoin and at aloe
protocol if you're interested in
learning more you can check out our
developer docs at docs. allow. gin. and
anyone who is building on top of aloe
can get funding from our getcoin grants
program so there's a Fun mimetic Loop
where we're using gitcoin to build
gitcoin to build gitcoin to build
gitcoin and hopefully the better uh that
results in better funding infrastructure
for the world and for ethereum that is
my talk thank you for having me
[Applause]
Devcon thank you very much for a super
nice talk um um yeah it's uh yeah quite
inspiring and I think it's like one of
those things that blockchains and
ethereum sort of promised that you know
we would have such uh nice applications
and we would have transparencies and
ways to vote and move uh move uh assets
around so it's really great that you're
Building Systems and applications like
this and allowing others to build the
same as well congrats on the new
protocol thank you um we have some
questions from the audience I'm really
happy that uh people actually subit
questions thank you very much um I think
one of them I can go with the first one
and they asked I was running a grants
program in web 3 with a monthly value of
100K I could not deploy most of it what
are some thoughts of where web3 Grant
programs are going wrong including
myself yeah well uh this is an
evolutionary design space and so I think
that the fact that sometimes these
programs go wrong doesn't mean that you
shouldn't do the grants program it means
that you should iterate towards your
ultimate goal and one of the things that
I think that grants programs do that we
need to get better at is defining their
goals upfront so it's really impossible
to say in the abstract what should I be
doing for my grants program you need to
Define what is the purpose of the grants
program are you building an education
grants program are you building a
protocol developer grants program or
something else what are the kpis how are
we going to uh design around those kpis
these grants programs are relative to
their design criteria and so you can
check out the getcoin grants canvas
which is a book that we wrote about how
to design a grants program if you want
to get better at running grants programs
so start at the foundations exactly very
nice thank you um another one a bit of a
technical one which I liked um was how
does quadratic funding address cibil
attacks cibil attacks are sock puppet
attacks that's basically uh if myig
Grant was losing out in a quadratic
funding round I could spin up a bunch of
sock puppets and pretend to be a bunch
of users and we've attempted to solve
that it's never really fully solved uh
with passport uh which is a identity
product that we've incubated at gitcoin
is now spun out of gitcoin and then
we're also using this thing called
cluster mapping which uses some really
Advanced Data science to Cluster
contributions to each other and to root
out Cil attacks so uh tldr use passport
use all the other great anti-il tools
out there in the ecosystem and use data
science to solve those problems nice um
we have time for one more question and
there's one more here um how can we
incentivize allocating Capital to public
goods which don't directly benefit web 3
uh for example climate
impact yeah uh my vision for how to how
to do this is that we basically fund our
shared needs in the blockchain ecosystem
by contributing to public goods funding
for our own ecosystems and if we can set
a norm that just 10% of that Capital
will go Upstream to ethereum to open
source to the world then as ethereum
scales and as web 3 scales eventually
we'll have a lot of funding that goes
Upstream to those global and planetary
public goods the other thing that we can
do is we can go to governments and Nos
and say hey we're better at allocating
Capital than you are look at all the
ways that we've done that please use our
infrastructure and so those are two ways
that I think over the next decade that
we're going to be solving those systemic
problems hopefully with onchain
Primitives right nice um we have one
minute left for question so I'm going to
be selfish and ask a personal not
personal question but one that I have
myself okay and you talked a lot about
plurality and this is something that
I've been hearing more and more about
this week actually and it was it seems
to be a sort of new thing that's like
coming up in conversation can you talk a
bit more about what you mean by that or
maybe even just Define it a little bit
if it's not clear yeah so plurality it
basically means that you don't put all
of the weight of your expectations on
one system or mechanism or group of
people and so plurality means that we
celebrate the diversity of approaches to
solving problems and you see this
manifested in the need for the ethereum
network to have client diversity at its
base layer if vital talked about it in
his talk this morning but basically uh
if one execution client goes down then
the other ones can pick up the slack and
uh you know that's an example of how
plurality is a prim a meta primitive for
resilience in these ecosystems and so I
just think that we should take that
philosophy of plurality and apply it to
our public goods funding layer of the
infrastructure not just the the base
layer of the network and hopefully that
means that we get more funding from more
directions and we're not overly Reliant
to or and beholden to any of them very
nice cool everything is so much emerging
like I mean it's it's good to it's
happening yeah um real quick uh someone
asked where you can get the book you can
get it at alob book. gitcoin doco it's a
free PDF or for 20 bucks you can get it
shipped to your house anywhere in the
world thanks thank you very much let's
thank the speaker
[Applause]
again
great I think we have two more minutes
uh while the next speaker joins us
um thanks much
[Music]
thank
you okay we're back for the second talk
thank you for staying with us um I think
it was a super nice introduction to the
stage three and I think the next talk
kind of Builds on a little bit the
similar ideas um like ethereum web 3 and
blockchains gave us all these promises
and I think is one of those promises
that everyone got so excited about and I
think it's great and I think for me it's
one of the like absolute dreams to build
towards but this talk kind of looks at a
bit what actually is a DA and like uh
are the things that people are calling
Dows actually Dows is a Discord server
with a multisig actually a DA all these
kinds of things so um yeah leas will
join us to give us a talk about th
everything to know and uh yeah welcome
to the stage thank you very much give a
round of
applause hey good afternoon
everybody um so I guess uh we're here to
talk about
Dows uh this talk is going to be about
hard truths it's going to be a bit spicy
like the food here and um for those of
you who don't know who I am a quick
intro I'm leis I've been in ethereum for
a bit I worked on solidity compiler in
the C++ ethereum um later I created
along with kristofh here um the da and
helped with the cleanup afterwards um
I'm was a Dev lead for the ryen network
and uh for a long time now I'm the
founder of Rodi uh the portfolio
management and tracking and accounting
tool that respects your
privacy so let's get some definitions
first what is a DA there can be many
definitions but um the the main thing is
that it's a smart
contract uh with a set of rules that
governs some kind of um cooperation
between uh
people trivia in the Thai language da is
a star I learned it very recently and um
it's also uh a name that was sometimes
given to girls um there is nice other
definitions like uh group with a bank
account crypto cop I really like the
word Financial flash mob because um you
know you have a lot of people who gather
together and they um just buy the
Constitution let's say or attempt to so
what is AD da good for um being a smart
contract it's auditable it's open source
it's transparent ad also um works on the
blockchain which is a transparent Ledger
and as such um you can see what it does
and what it touches it's very easy to
use you don't need to set up a company
you just press a button and you deploy
um a contract an audited contract so you
probably use a template you just
customize it a bit uh and it's also very
cheap there is only gas fees if you have
to do a company you have to do notaries
uh gas uh like legal fees there's a lot
of work it's accessible to everybody
Dows don't discriminate about
jurisdiction about nationality about
anything what are the problems there's
many problems with Dows coordination is
one um regulatory unclarity something
that we're going to uh talk a bit
about many Dows perform decentralization
theater we're going to talk about this
quite a bit and there is participation
incentives um if many any of you have
worked with a Dao or anything uh you
will probably notice that after the
honeymoon period you tend to lose
interest um there's many examples like
Thea um y pleasure NS uh friends with
benefits optimism there is many there is
no point talking about them here in this
part so let's go to the to the hard
truth what are the problems with Dows a
very big problem
is absence of regulations everything I
say is not legal advice I have I I'm not
um a lawyer in any way but who is liable
for example when a doubt does something
we are talking about liability always
who is liable when a DA does something
is it the deployer is it the author is
it the participants the token holders
in the end it may not matter um what
many Dows do today and what we did back
then in 16 is we didn't deploy um uh
that original uh Dow we just created the
bite the the code and we gave the bite
code to the community and they deployed
it uh multiple times I don't even
remember how many 40 50 and then they
were chosen randomly by um um a random
function in
slack um this was also a way to you know
say that it wasn't deployed by a
particular company in the end all this
kind of stuff don't matter if they
actually want to say that a company uh
deployed it they just would write it
this is from the SEC paper on the Dow
and what it says is that on or about
April 1926 sloy deployed the da code on
the ethereum blockchain they completely
disregarded um having the deployment uh
as as um like a member from the
community they just complet dis the
entire thing so the point here being
that doesn't really matter in the end if
someone wants to say that you deployed a
DA they will just say that you deployed
a DA uh when you work for a DA and I
have done that and I guess many of you
actually have worked for a DA you
probably have a tax account at some
point and they ask you hey so where is
the invoice for this payment you're like
invoice what's that you have issued an
invoice right okay you're right
optimism but what is optimism where
where is it where is the jurisdiction
where is it located um is it located in
the EU you're also located in the EU so
you need to pay vat um there is many
many questions and the worst thing is
that when they make these questions
you're already screwed they can just
claim whatever they want if you can't
prove it they can claim that you need to
retroactively give pay V on every one of
your invoices this has happen to some
people so it's actually a really
dangerous thing working for it now um
participating in a DA there is uh
potential legal
liabilities this is from uh ok da um
they basically at some point um wanted
them to shut down the C
cftc and they gave them a penalty so
they found the da is a person and they
gave them a penalty of
[Music]
,000 now who is responsible to pay for
this um are the token holders
responsible is the governance
responsible would they hold the vote to
pay this fine there's many questions
about who is liable for for for for a
all this talk is about questions not
answers I I don't have the answers by
the way um taxes everybody loves taxes
right especially Dows um Dows operate
and many of them make money
uh that money is not taxed at all
because most Dows don't belong in any
jurisdiction they will tell you we in
the ethereum jurisdiction well take tell
that to the lawyer um if they are under
a jurisdiction they would probably have
to do some kind of AML and
kyc so how do they do that even the
question is always which jurisdiction
does the Dow fall under because that's
where you would see does it need to do
AML does it need to pay taxes and so on
and so
forth
um regulations aside which don't have
much uh answers we can also talk about
something really important which is the
decentralization theater that many deos
do
today this is the biggest statement that
this um uh talk wants to make is that
there are no doubts today almost
everything that you call out today is
really just not a
da um the majority of stuff is just
Discord administer organizations you
just open a Discord server you deploy a
four out of seven multisig and then you
deploy a token that is owned by the
multisig um now who are the multisig
owners uh the signers it's probably you
and your friends or you and your four
addresses or seven addresses and then
after you give it to the community then
a day passes or a week or a month and
then you rck pull or you just you know
you you close down it you tried it's
fine you did your best but you have
already sold most of the tokens your
community became your exit uh liquidity
that's
definitely not at all that's that's a
scam there is uh there's many many many
scams uh like that out there this is the
most obvious noted thing there is other
things though something that many
companies in this field and many big
names are absolutely uh uh doing and
it's it's
horrible what many people do is that
they create a product they have a
company behind the product then they say
we could do better we could actually
make a dow and then um we have two c
tables we have the original investors of
the first company and then we have also
the token holders they're also investors
in a sense um you raise double the
amount of money because also the people
put money into the token so they
actually become your exit liquidity
slowly you don't need to promise them
anything the Dow doesn't promise
anything ever but just because of
proximity to the original product of
proximity
to the original um team and original
company the token gets value and in many
of these cases it gets a lot of value
and then both for the founders and for
the VC investors um the original company
has beautiful exit liquidity through the
token um this is something that many uh
big names today are doing and I have
lost respect for basically a lot of ogs
in the field that are just doing this
which is
uh you could call it a scam but it's
kind of a smart way to scam people it's
not a D um I was talking with someone um
who was trying to advise me on what to
do with RI and I had problems like there
is always problems about liabilities
regulation taxes you know we we're a
German company we have to pay a lot of
taxes there is legal questions about
everything sometimes do we have to kyc
our users you know why don't you just
solve it easily just make a dow just
make a BVI Foundation everything is easy
you just make it out and then you just
sidestep
everything so Dow is not a way to
sidestep regulations it shouldn't be
um another thing that Dows tend to do in
order to create the centralization
theater is to attract governance
participants so they make a token they
air drop it they call it airdropping
responsibility to you and they ask you
to become a delegate in the Dow so um
you make it look like the delegates are
deciding
uh you get big names I am actually in
some Dows and I have regretted it
because I gave legitimacy to Dows uh
that do not deserve it in Truth what
happens is uh they plan they do
everything and what you do is just
rubber stamp but by doing the rubber
stamping what you end up doing is giving
legitimacy as a big name in the field to
something that actually not a
dow so um D governance is what uh some
DS use in order to legitimize the
project uh and then plutocracy
essentially um as token voting
goes uh the most of the tokens they have
um very very very bad distribution it's
either the founder or the investors that
hold the majority of the token they they
decide what to do then they vote to do
it and then um sometimes they hide it by
doing the uh friends or employee emplo
es of the foundation or whatever that
have delegated the tokens to and then
it's appears as if it's decentralized
but in reality if you see where does the
token delegation come from it's actually
from the
founders so we're going to do a few case
studies we're going to take it ens maker
da and
optimism um ens this is the how ens was
was uh um split 25% to core contributors
25% as an airdrop to everybody that had
an enss name 50% to the Dow Treasury
itself um then um they made a
foundation they it's in the K Island
nonprofit it represents the Dow in the
real world and the directors were
actually appointed by governance so
there was a governance vote I am a part
of the Dow so I did vote for who is the
um uh the head of the
foundation the NS Foundation actually
tries to solve the problems that I
mentioned before which is the liability
for the participants um taxation for the
because the Dow actually makes money
like all these ens names that you guys
uh are are getting part of the fee or
all the Fe I don't remember goes to the
to the Dow this is the the income and
this this is why the foundation exists
it it can also enter into contract so if
you get a grant you can actually put the
ens Foundation as your um um
counterparty and then there is enss labs
this is the main uh uh company that
develops the protocol um and it it has a
founding team the they have governance
they have big names um they have a
security Council which is the very very
top voter here this is just for um uh to
veto against governance attacks the
treasur is managed by karpaty everything
is executed on chain the governance does
own indeed the token it owns it can do
things uh on chain so the governance has
power in enss unfortunately um while the
Dow does have control then who controls
the da is that Stills Labs has quite a
strong presence in the Dow not as bad as
other Dows but still if you see like
some people here are indeed part of in
labs and some people here if you check
the delegations that they have they're
actually also by like one or two people
from NS Dow uh NS
Labs it's kind of a doubt it has issues
but it's sufficiently decentralized I
would say from the um test cases that I
case studies that I'm making here it's
probably the
best so then going to maker Dow um maker
Dow it was founded by run Christensen uh
in
2015 they created the maker token um we
all know it it has it's an amazing defi
protocol it has created the the cdps the
first uh decentralized stemble coin like
Sai known as D at the time then they
launched a multic collateral die uh they
dissolved the foundation because they
said now we decentralized then run came
back in 2022 um and then rebranded to
Sky and then regretted it it's a bit of
a right
now the allocation of maker though it's
bit weird it's like 69.5 to F project
and 15 to the team
okay then we have run run is the founder
as I said and he's essential he is
basically a guy that does
everything the problem as stated in the
podcast the uned one um can run fix the
S state of Dow
governance the is that there is Dow
governance in maker but it's not a dow
and it's absolutely not not governance
um when you own most of the maker and
you delegate it to your friends uh and
delegates are paid by how much um they
are delegated to then everybody will do
what you say at that point it's not
really a
da it's basically runes da it basically
only anons are supposed to be able to
delegate it to because of fear of safety
so the very few big holders which are
funds the original investors they do not
delegate to anybody because they can't
delegate to anons um and then I don't
know if you read the forums there is a
lot of things I don't want to go into
many details but it looks more like a
cult than a DA so I would say that make
a DA is not a da it's probably a cult I
I really don't know what it is right
now then going to optimism this is
another D that I actually participating
actively in and I have kind of regretted
it uh da launched in April um 2022 they
kept a big part like what 20% for retor
active public goods funding this is why
I actually went to for the public goods
uh they have a partner F fund that's
managed by what they created later a
foundation and the investors and the
team also got a big
allocation uh they also created the K
allance Foundation it does exactly the
same thing as the NS foundation so that
it can interact with with real world
entities but the problem starts here
that it's towards the evolution of the
collective governance I have an issue
with this and you will see what it is
they had for they had four years mandate
but they hope to decentralize before
that the hope is is
dying so governance the governance of um
optimism is like this these are the
biggest delegates I'm also there um they
have big names uh in delegate it's very
very well or organized in seasons and
they have two um uh bomal governance so
basically it's the token house and the
citizen house the token house is what is
in every single Dow so um the op token
it's just plutocracy essentially and
then the citizen house the citizen house
is that they just choose people from the
community they give them um um a buds as
they call it and then it's one person
one
vote uh the citizen house decides for
rpdf and has a vetto against um the
token house if there is some kind of
capture unfortunately neither house owns
anything the governance is powerless
they do nothing it's all just bells and
whistles they have the super chain um
it's a collective of chains that's
building on the obst they have manage to
attract very big names uh and the idea
is to create an interruptable um layer
to
um What attracted me to um optimism was
the rpdf the idea of um the sequencer
fees being directed towards public goods
each super chain actually is supposed to
direct a percentage of their fees
towards public goods in reality at the
moment because the sequencer fees are
quite low uh they are still using the
20% allocation of the original token um
the problem is that the decision of
everything here still lies with the
foundation governance doesn't doesn't
deal with this like nobody decides apart
from the foundation about how this will
be
done so optimism is the definition of
decentralization theater it really is
probably what should be in the books
about decentralization of theater the
Dow owes nothing you you have governance
that does nothing it's just rubber
stumping the foundation says we will do
this yes or no well I mean they own most
of the government participant so it will
always be yes um the structure is
suggested by the foundation the rpdf
structure to the foundation the rules
how much money will
go everything is is managed by the
foundation there is a promise for
decentralization but it does take
forever and at some point you start to
wonder like I I want to put a snapshot
that we voted that we want to have more
decentralized and then say okay we'll
try and that's it I don't know so
optimism is an amazing uh Tech stack I'm
a very big fan actually of the tech
stack I use all the optimis chains it's
a very well-run business they have
attracted the biggest names like Kraken
for ink base for uh coinbase for base
but it's a company it's a business it's
it's a very well-run business it is not
a
d so is it is it like is is basically
all hope lost should doubts not
exist well there are some doubts that
actually are what I would consider a dow
like the Constitution guys they just
wanted to buy the Constitution they just
all gathered and said let's buy why the
Constitution 47 million in eth was
raised in a very very short amount of
time they still didn't get it they lost
to a less amount dollar amount bid but
they I think that they didn't have
enough uh for all the processing Etc so
they said okay we we are we are not
going to do this and then they
disbanded then there is y uh Y is is
probably my favorite thing that I
consider a doubt today since 2020
they're still continuing uh defi
protocol very smart devs uh the token
was fairly launched so basically
everybody had the same opportunity to
get it infamously the founder got zero
and he left early and it still continues
despite the founder leaving early this
this is the true test of the Dow no
biking just a nice product and it still
exists this is exactly it they just a
small team building awesome stuff and uh
lastly as a good example is m Dow a
bunch of people said okay let's try to
fund ethereum ecosystem it got summoned
by Amin on the 14th of February it has
given over 1.4 million ecosystem grants
maybe more I'm not sure about my numbers
here people like flashboard through
blocks and also Ry um took a d Grant
from Mok down the members coordinate
it's all open source uh if you don't
like what the Moc da wants to give funds
at you just can Rage Quit which is
basically a mechanism that also kind of
came from the original Dow of
exiting so yes there is hope and use for
Dows it just not what Dows are trying to
do
today the take-home method basically is
very very simple a DA is not a company
like really just everybody needs to get
it into their heads that a dow is really
not a company it's not a way to shift
liability to the users it is not a way
to avoid regulations it's it's not
optimism so the decentralization theater
please don't do that this is is disgrace
and it's not a way to lose participants
with fake promises
over whatever you want to say that we
going to do public goods for example
with optimism and then basically change
your mind six months later and now is a
very simple thing it's a quick way to
just band together and do something um
you can coordinate permissionless over a
smart contract and build something nice
and it doesn't need to last forever you
can just make a d for one small thing we
can make a d for something here in
Thailand then is banded when we go back
home you don't need to uh keep a dow
like a
company I guess that's mostly it uh
thank you very much
guys thank you very much um it's a very
nice talk and it was yeah nice to see a
kind of honest exploration of these
things um uh yeah I hope people don't
think that this is bad or anything I
really appreciate seeing these things so
that I can actually understand what is
going on and what people are actually
doing and and seeing how you can build
it better either yourself or how they
can improve and we have a few questions
um some nice ones I'll start with a
spicy one because I think you might like
it um will there oh no it's gone I have
to uh so um something I didn't mention
before but people have been using it you
can upvote questions okay and uh so this
was one of the ones that was mostly
upvoted so why do you think we have not
seen anti Pluto ratic on J governance
structures because of Cil I guess we
can't easily find out who is who uh this
is exactly what optimism is trying with
the citizen house but then you decide
who is who by just giving it to people
that you know and then
that's not really equal um equal
opportunity governance so do you think
some sort of identity things would help
yeah but they have been trying them with
gitcoin as as you saw before for so long
and it's not
easy and so what does accountability
look like in a dow structure how do we
create a stronger onchain culture of
accountability accountability yeah good
question
uh well being accountable to the Dow
would mean say that you get a grant and
then you have some milestones and then
you you have to
uh get them and then if you don't uh
finish the marones then you just are bu
from not only this Dow but from other
Dows this is for Grant recipients but
accountability in let's say I don't know
participation
Etc yeah this is a very hard problem to
incentivize participation because most
of these Dows for example you get all
these people to work on it out and they
are
um it's just unpaid work for most of
them there's a question that kind of
touches on this point so you suggested
that there's uncertainty about liability
for Dow participants how however some
legal Trends are becoming clear don't
you see that there are some obvious uh
candidates for
accountability candidates for what what
I didn't really understand candidates
for accountability so I guess yeah like
legal things like filing your taxes or
oh yeah yeah but this is not really this
accountability towards the state not
accountability to the DA or to the other
participants I I when I hear of
accountability I just think more of um
how you are accountable to the DA is as
an organization not to the your
jurisdiction or the
state uh okay
so so what is your opinion for an
optimal framework to build a real Dow
what is needed for a real Dow as I said
I don't think a Dows should be as they
are today they it should be like a
simple thing just pop it up solve a
problem disband it or just like y did
build an actual product not a DA and
then a product just build an actual
product other people are around the
product and then they will just keep
building it you can call it a dow you
can call it a band of friends doing
something I think that the Dow word is
completely overused this is also uh a
piece of advice that is floating around
with people who are thinking about
launching tokens for not necessarily
governance or whatever but for like
protocols and things like that it's also
like do the protocol and make it work
and then uh so will there be a time
where we will actually think before just
doing the next cool thing
honestly I think that this also depends
a lot on on us the community because
everybody seems to approve of this stuff
the you know if we don't use those
things if we don't approve if we don't
go to the big events organized by those
people with the lot of money that they
get through this decentralization
theater then maybe they would think
again before trying to do this but if we
as a community really just keep
approving this they will keep doing it
it's really up to us to just say no guys
this is this is this is a come this is
actually I don't know if it's legal but
it absolutely and certainly is not
ethical like it really shouldn't be done
this
way so I think that's about all the time
we have for questions but I think it's a
very nice point to end on and I think
it's a point that summarizes your talk
very well like I think it's super
important that you give this talk to
call out certain Behavior to say like
hey look uh this is the way we should be
we should be better U so if we want to
build a nice future we should build
better and like I think there's lots of
Hope for that in the aterian community I
think like lots of people do have good
intentions so yes yes absolutely I mean
this is why I'm still here yeah exactly
so thank you very much again and uh we
take one minute break before the next
speaker my pleasure
[Music]
hello uh welcome back for the next
session we continue on the Dow topic and
we continue I think on a similar point
that we touched on in before so how do
we do how do we align incentives with
different funding how do we um use the
tokens that we have in our Dows how do
we um yeah like uh should how do we
balance the risk of the long-term kind
of goals that we have with the kind of
short-term need needs for incentives
that we have within Dow so um I welcome
the speaker to the stage to give us a
view of liquid staking in Dows thank you
very
much hello hello
hello all right 20 minutes uh great to
see everyone my name is Dennis Bertram I
am the CEO and co-founder of tally uh we
are one of the largest Dow tooling
infrastructure companies in the space we
build a lot of solutions for and
protocols at large we're really focused
on making this new kind of decentralized
organization really work so today what
I'm going to talk about normally when I
do this talk or talks like this I talk
pretty generally about Dows the problems
the challenges you know really excited
to have seen uh left speak you know he's
big I'm a big fan of his and uh you know
he brings up a lot of points but today
I'm going to speak about something
pretty specific uh really one particular
solution that we believe in very
strongly right now which is staking for
Dows which maybe for many of you might
be a new kind of idea and you're sort of
like okay what is the staking for Dows
so I'm going to dig into it a bit of
course so first to sort of talk about
Dows really at a high level just sort of
set the stage uh Dows are the new future
form of Corporations and when we think
about corporations we're actually
talking about the largest asset class
out there in the world right um last
year the corporation market cap hit $123
trillion so when we think about why are
we building Dows what are Dows for what
is the opportunity here actually that
number is the opportunity because we can
convert some meaningful percentage of
that into
decentralization so as I mentioned Dows
represent a new corporate form uh but
there's something interesting here
because you know M Jennings put up a
tweet where he said tokens are not
equity and that's absolutely correct
because Dow's actually aren't
corporations uh token holders are not
shareholders but I want to give you a
little int little analogy Right Here
Right In traditional corporations you
have these shareholders let's take
something like a gold mine you have this
gold mine you have these employees the
managers and you have these shareholders
if all the shareholders die in a
terrible plane crash in the Andes um
it's a terrible sad story but the M
continues to work right they can
continue to mine gold they can sell it
in the market they can earn revenue and
they can pay one another right that's
kind of a traditional corporation uh so
corporations can exist without their
shareholders even though shareholders do
have a specific sort of function in the
corporate form but Dows actually die
without their token holders right this
seems kind of obvious but if you think
about it you know if you take your
protocol and you take your Dow and
everyone gets together at a big party
they eat some bad Sushi and they all die
it's very sad but also your Dow is dead
the protocol is dead right and this is a
really big distinction the token hold
are really core and critical to your
organization in a way that in the
corporate form shareholders are
not the problem is especially today that
Dows are actually misaligned with token
holders right um and I'm going to talk
about this in the next coming slides but
high level contributors that bring value
to Dows today are actually forced to
exit these organizations to actualize
their share value and operators because
of the misalignment of incentives are
actually incentivized to cap capture
rather than collaborate in
Dows so this is kind of the phases of
dows that go through and I'll talk about
these really briefly but all protocols
start in something that I call the
experimental phase and in fact most of
crypto has spent most of its lifetime in
the experimental phase and the
experimental phase is when people a
bunch of people get together they have
some idea they're going to write some
smart contract code they're going to
create a lending protocol something like
that this is an experiment you know I
think if you look in crypto a lot of
times we like to talk about crypto being
an experiment everything we're building
is an experiment well experiments are
quite interesting especially in crypto
because experiments capture value via
speculative price appreciation right if
you put work into something that is an
experiment the way you get value out is
through speculative price appreciation
and we have a lot of tools that enable
us to do this namely exchanges um then
we have inflection where value
actualization
as a kind of failure and business the
for Final Phase when Dows that actually
make it past this point succeed so let
me dig into these really quickly
speculative appreciation I've talked a
little bit about that that is
essentially I join this Dow it's a cool
idea everybody loves it it's hype Vibes
are popping off token price goes up
great because I have brought some energy
to this I've brought my own
contributions to this I've helped create
value right you know a lot of
organizations here go from zero to a
billion overnight you have helped create
value fantastic but how do I actualize
my share of the value that I've created
well I have to take my tokens and sell
them right but this is kind of oh I was
going to swear this this this sucks
right because what you're doing is this
model actually forces out the operators
who bring the greatest value to your
protocol out of the protocol right they
have to essentially sell their part
participation to get their value and now
they're no longer aligned right the
success of this organization is forcing
out its very operators who contribute to
that
excess so the actualization is failure
this is very critical when we look
across the ecosystem why does the chart
look like this so often right of course
it's speculation but it's because at the
very top here the only logical operation
for operators and operators I defin is
anyone who's helping to operate a dow is
to exit right there's some price at
which you've priced in all the Vibes all
the hype all the Riz of an organization
and now it could only go down and now
it's a race to the exit and this kills
even really good successful ideas
because there's no path to longevity
because you force out the operators
whove created this
value now if a protocol succeeds at this
and this is where where we'll get into
staking um protocols become businesses
right what you want is these people
who've contributed value and they've
contributed to the growth of this
organization you want them to stay you
want to keep them aligned with the
project that you're working on right
they should not have to sell their
participation in order to continue uh to
be able to get some value out and right
and this this goes to kind of a core
thing about governance Dow tokens right
they're intering in financial utility
with governance utility right this token
is used to operate a protocol but it's
also an asset right people talk about I
have most of my net worth in XYZ da
right it's an asset but it's also a
utility so what we need to do in order
for protocols to become businesses is
use a mechanism to return value in a way
that doesn't force them out and what I'm
going to argue here is that staking is
actually the right way to do
this so to solve the alignment we need
to fix
incentives so staking is the web three
native way to align Dows we know staking
works we know staking is compliant right
e does staking many many l1s do staking
staking is already product Market fit
for Capital and Assets in web 3 I mean
maybe it's a little bit reductive to say
but in many ways the number number one
product Market fit with crypto is use
your money to make more
money staking though is also the
compliant way to return value and
compliance here is a very important term
first of all I'm not a lawyer but I'll
talk to you a little bit about what we
mean by compliance
here in
corporations they can return value bya
dividends of course no corporations do
that anymore because the entire world is
just meme coins and everything's kind of
but that's fine the point is
they can return value in the form of
dividends and if token holders were just
to receive money from the protocol you
actually are turning your protocol into
a security you can't just return value
to everyone who holds a token because
they have contributed potentially
nothing right this is very important we
have to find compliant ways to return
Capital even in whatever the new
regulatory regime may be and staking
does this because staking requires some
sort sort of value some sort of effort
on the behalf of the token holder to
return value right you stake your eth in
order ear inflationary rewards you stake
your tokens and unit Staker and delegate
to someone in order to receive a portion
of the fees
right now quickly rewards can be revenue
or inflation people talk to me about
this a lot and I'll talk about this
really briefly first of all protocols
need to return value to token holders
there needs to be Revenue there needs to
be cash flows if you think that this can
go on forever with no revenue and no
cash flows you're deluding yourself
right these things must become
businesses in the long term to survive
yeah maybe it's fine that it's been four
years and you know there's no cash flows
and all that stuff but it doesn't last
forever and it doesn't last forever for
a very practical reason the majority of
these Protocols are VC funded and these
funds have shelf lives and at the end of
the shelf life they have to get rid of
these tokens and when they compare the
world against like holding eth or
holding your token and the need to
return value in the fund there's going
to be a hard decision to make right and
we're not going to be able to support
the future of Finance via speculative
price appreciation because today the
market is absolutely filled with things
that are driving speculative price
appreciation you may hear people joke
about Dow tokens as being meme coins and
if we never return value if there's
never cash flows that's exactly what
they are
thank you the other one is inflationary
rewards and inflationary reward
sometimes gets a bad rep right you
create a dow token and now you're going
to do inflationary rewards and people
say oh you created this Monopoly money
and now you're just going to give out
more Monopoly money it's like
following right that's not true
the majority of staking rewards are
inflationary rewards ethereum has no
cash flows right nobody pays in a way
that you can actually create some other
sorts of value it just returns you more
e right but that's actually correct this
is the right way to do it in many cases
because in many of these protocols you
have a large number of token holders who
aren't doing anything right they haven't
provided any value they weren't initial
investors maybe they just bought this
stuff off Unis swap what value does that
bring to your protocol we need a way to
identify the operators of protocols in a
strategic clear way that's transparent
and inflationary rewards allows you to
inflate out people who are doing nothing
and staking is the decentralized way to
allow people to choose to participate I
going to have to go a little bit faster
so I'm going to jump through this a
little bit okay inflationary rewards
have Dows manage their operators that's
what I just talking about the point here
is if you have a group of people who are
doing nothing you need to try and
inflate them out of the system right you
can't take people's tokens that's not
web three aligned you have to give them
an option if you are participating in
being an operator of the protocol if you
continue to bring or organizational
capital and value to the system you
should be rewarded with more ownership
over this system because you are
participating and so you can use
inflationary rewards to slowly push out
the dead weight and protocols now you
may not agree with me on this and you
don't have to use inflationary rewards
that's all fine but this is something I
feel quite strongly about because if you
look around there's a lot of dead slowly
push out in protocols now you may not
agree with me on this and you don't have
to slowly push out in protocols now you
may not agree with with me on this and
you don't have to use inflationary
rewards that's all fine use inflationary
rewards that's all fine but this is
something I feel quite strongly about
because if you look around slowly push
out the dead weight in protocols now you
may not agree with me on this and you
don't have to use inflationary rewards
that's all fine but this is something I
feel quite slowly push out the dead
weight in protocols now you may not
agree with me on this and you don't have
to use inflationary rewards that's all
fine but this is something I feel quite
strongly about because if you look
around there's a lot of dead into
participating again a superpower of
dows so staking fixes Dows this is what
I've been trying to talk a little bit
about maybe I didn't express enough the
sort of like core problem here but we
align the operator class we align the
founders and core teams we align the
investors and we line The Wider
Community with success right no longer
is this just a pump and dump kind of
operation we want to build something
that grows over
time uh tally build staking for
um feel free to come and talk to me
about this more if you want to
understand a little bit more about uh
our perspective what we're doing here
but most importantly this is what we
want to leave you with we need staking
as the web3 compliant tool to enable
success of our organizations they are
not meme coins but they're going to be
meme coins if we don't act on creating
long-term sustainable mechanisms so
that's my talk
I have three minutes I'm not sure if
that was supposed to go into the
questions answer period thank you very
much uh it was very nice and you speak
so clearly and so uh energetically that
the guys even came and brought more
chairs thank you you're like pulling the
crowd in this is really this is more we
need more of this it's really nice thank
you very much pleasure and we have some
time for some questions uh so maybe I
will read them out and you can have an
answer but uh yeah so the first question
I think maybe it's asking for a little
summary of the talk actually how does
staking do dow tokens for a protocol
bring value isn't it just locked
liquidity in smart contracts okay this
is a great point no because when you
lock the liquidity you demand something
right so the way high level works is you
have your tokens you stake them but you
have to pick an operator to represent
you in governance is a delegate right so
you say okay I'm staking my tokens I'm
picking my delegate now in order for me
to receive my staking rewards the
delegate must do some sort of work in
the Dow right we're working with
arbitrum to build staking for arbitrum
they're using a tool called karma which
creates a score for delegates and they
say okay if you reach this minimum score
I don't know 88% on the karma score you
are eligible for your rewards what that
means is token holders have to watch
their delegate closely because if the
delegate goes on vacation and doesn't
show up for a vote you don't get paid
right and if you don't want to delegate
to someone you delegate to yourself now
you can earn both the delegates rewards
and your own token holder rewards right
but this is important because it demands
that you operate the protocol and this
effectively
turns participants into kind of
independent contractors right you're not
being paid for just being viby and
hanging out you're being paid for doing
the work of operating the protocol or
making sure your selected delegate does
their job in operating the protocol
uh so for me this kind of touches on the
point that you say it becomes a
professional Manor like for me I don't
know like I think people do their job
when they have a fear of losing
something like of course yes you're
incentivized by getting money at the end
of the week but you do your job purely
because you don't want to lose the money
at the end of the week so do you think
this also plays a role in staking or
yeah one of the things that is based on
is the opportunity cost of Capital right
if you have certainly large amount of
money there are a lot of ways to earn
yield in traditional staking you have
slashing here the slashing operates on
your opportunity cost right if at the
end of one year your delegate didn't
show up you lose all the income that you
could have earned you lose the
opportunity cost of your Capital this is
quite important because in Dows there
aren't objective yes and no answers we
can't take people's tokens for having
making decisions that we consider wrong
because that you need these minority
protections so you can at least say well
no you're not qualified to earn these
rewards and that's the sort of mechanism
that you lose right so for professional
delegates they can go out they can pay
for food you know they don't have to do
some retr pgf where they got to like beg
for their rent you know six months later
this is how we do it in a professional
way and do you see this so one of the
things that I kind of wondered when I
first started hearing about that was
like maybe I do this as a profession
like if I'm interested in politics or
whatever maybe I actually do this as a
profession do you see people actually
doing this and like staking enabling
that there are large organizations
already in crypto who are professional
delegates they hire teams they' have
analysts many investors now take the
governance seriously where they have
analyst teams you know you look at large
organizations like black Roth that
participates in the arbitrum Dow you
look at VCS like panta that are actively
participate in their Dows so yes we we
see these these large not necessarily
large but professional um working group
of folks who focus on these protocols
quite cool and so what we have another
minute so we can have one more question
so what is the first stage of growing
and identifying our ecosystems operating
in class so how do we get yeah yeah so
that is work right because if you get it
wrong you you can screw up things
majorly you really need to identify who
needs your protocol who's excited about
your protocol and what the is between so
it depends on kind of what your protocol
is if it's a VC backed protocol probably
your first operating class are going to
be your VCS if was a Community First
protocol it's probably going to be the
people who contribute to the energy of
getting stuff done every day if it's a
protocol that's composable and people
build on top of it it's probably the
folks that are building on top of it as
you get more mature it also becomes more
attractive for the thirdparty groups
things like kotki or Gauntlet or stable
node stable lab l2b many of these other
organizations who are available as a
professional class to help uh operate
cool uh I think because you finish the
talk one minute early we have one last
one if you want I hope they they don't
uh complain to me because I think like
lots of questions came in um so one of
them spicy which uh Dow do you like the
most I can't pick favorites no okay good
um one other one before that that that
came in before the time ran out um how
would arise in AI agents operate
protocols change the need for Native
tokens and staking yeah AI agents
actually don't change the equation right
one of the things that's incredible
about Dows is that we've built a
corporate entity that AI agents can
actually natively interact with right
when Bitcoin first came out one of the
amazing things about it was I could send
you an email that says I love you uh and
you'd feel loved or I could say you send
you an email that says here's a dollar
and you don't have anything right
Bitcoin changed that I can send you a
dollar and that was a major blocker for
machine machines actually participating
as co-equal partners in the economy now
with Dows AI agents machines can
actually be valuable contributors to
these ecosystems and they will also need
renumeration for the services because AI
actually has many of the same
requirements that humans do right they
have to have some physical location
where the servers are they have to pay
for electricity so they will also need
to be able to pay be paid for their
services so this aligns very much with
creating some sort of cash flow stream
that pays for
compute very nice thanks very much well
now I think we're a little bit overtime
so maybe we can thank the speaker once
again this was the first you closed the
first session of stage three in Devcon 7
thank you very much thank
you so um now maybe we take five minutes
break uh in a few minutes we will come
back for the privacy and Cipher Punk uh
track so I think it's a bit of a switch
in topics um yeah join us in five
minutes and just for house keeping again
toilets are outside to the left there's
some snacks around scan the QR codes ask
questions upload other questions and
yeah see you in a few minutes thanks
very much
[Music]
oh
patience sorry about the delay we're
still waiting for the next session to uh
start bear with us a few minutes thanks
very much
[Music]
hello uh we're terribly sorry um but
unfortunately this session is going to
be
cancelled uh on the plus side it's a
room full of privacy people and if
you're here to talk about um the Privacy
ecosystem now you can talk to each other
everyone's free for the next 20 minutes
so the next session will start in 20
minutes at 3 p.m. sharp thanks for your
patience and sorry for the inconvenience
see you
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
e
for
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
for
e
[Music]
okay we're ready for the next session um
yeah there's always a minute for a
change over it but as the last talk gave
us a little tour of the cipher Punk
culture that's building up the next talk
gives us a bit of a tour of The Clash of
cultures that is sort of happening in
crypto at the moment as the cipher punks
are kind of getting going now it's kind
of cool like the the communities
building up there's also this sort of
mem coin culture and the dgen culture
that like okay maybe there's some uh
overlap between the two but there's also
some quite clash of the values so I
think the next talk will be nice to give
us a view of financial nihilism versus
the F culture from alos join us thank
you
[Music]
hello uh thank you for having me my name
is alos and today the title of my talk
is financial nihilism versus Force
culture the battle for ethereum show I
know it sounds weird right uh so uh a
bit of background on me I previously
founded the radical project which is a
censorship resistant and privacy
preserving Network for code
collaboration
you can think of it as a decentralized
alternative to GitHub it's a one of its
kind uh what radical tries to do is
basically ensure Open Access open as in
open source everywhere while at the same
time actually uh trying to protect the
privacy of of the different contributors
radical is live uh as of last month we
had a 1.0 moment it's usable it's not
vaporware please go use it uh and let us
know what you think uh but um over the
last two years I was also uh I have been
also contributing to a project that is
called drips uh which is um a
decentralized toolkit for funding public
goods that is focusing on uh dependency
trees and drips takes takes a very
opinionated take on how to fund public
goods the way the system works is that
um a fun organization in this this is a
real case with enss selects a number of
uh projects that they consider critical
uh this could be part of their developer
grants this could be part of the retr
pgf program we have multiple different
use cases uh but what they do is
effectively they come together they
decide on which projects are important
they set weights for each projects as
you can see behind me and then after
that they decide to allocate some
capital and that Capital can go as a
oneof payment or it can take place uh
using U by the second payments so that's
the first part uh but where get where
drips gets more interesting is that as
we on board these different open source
projects within the system what we do is
we um ask them to specify on chain their
maintainers uh and additionally we ask
them to specify on chain their
dependencies um and through that process
effectively we building a a tree uh
where Capital flows through um and the
problem that we're trying to solve is I
think like best illustrated by this
graphic I'm sure that many of you have
seen this but the main idea behind this
problem is that we have critical
infrastructure out there um on the
internet um and many times you have a
random person somewhere you know
somewhere in the world like like
tirelessly you know trying to keep that
that package you know wellmaintained and
clearly that's unsustainable and we
think that we have to do
better um the North Star we have with
drips um is this idea of what we call
continuous dependency funding what's
fascinating one of the many fascinating
things about ethereum is that you can
have these um programmable protocols
that generate Revenue um the model that
we want to prove to the world is that
you can have those Dows and protocols
that do generate Revenue but actually
you can now have completely new value
flows for developers imagine every time
a dollar is traded in Unis swap you know
every piece of dependency that actually
powers that that project uh to be able
to receive maybe
0.001 right we think that these are the
things that actually are really possible
um with with crypto and you know we try
to make that happen uh but today I'm not
going to talk to you um about drips and
mechan design and all of those things
instead I want to talk to you about some
of the things we hear as we onboard
different open source projects to
ethereum and over the last year we have
on boarded uh more than 200 uh open
source projects to ethereum and and some
of those projects the majority actually
are non crypto um they don't work in our
industry and many times they also you
know don't understand our industry uh
some examples that you can see behind me
uh this year we managed to bring the RAS
programming language on chain uh through
a project that they have that's called G
to RS uh we also managed to bring on
chain uh a really popular um uh front
and framework that is called zelte uh
and then many many many more uh projects
and as we board them we actually get to
talk to them um and when we talk to them
this is where interesting things happen
uh because our worldview uh living and
breathing within ethereum and crypto
networks many times is completely
different to what they perceive so today
I want to share some of those um some of
those learnings with you uh and
specifically I want to focus on a few
criticism that we keep hearing over and
over again and I want to cut straight to
the core Point uh which is by far the
most important thing and the you know
most depressing thing I have to say that
we keep hearing from non crypto
developers is this that basically hey
ethereum is interesting but you know
like it feels like a casino to us and
and it's so disappointing um especially
for people that like you know we we work
in the space we see the upside and the
potential of that space that this is
still you know the dominant P perception
that that that that people have about
our space and it's not just you know and
it's not just non crypto folks like
recently many well-known crypto thinkers
like poia a person that like his his
writings have actually been educating us
over the years he basically he wrote the
exact same thing he's like you know what
that I'm done with this this space
is just a casino it gets worse every
year right so so there's something
problematic here and um I wanted to
share some thoughts with regards to how
I'm looking into this and how I'm trying
to explain
this and in order to do this I had to
start on this on this concept of
financial nihilism this is not a well
defined concept uh but the way I
understand it Financial nihilism is
characterized by a loss of faith in
established systems and a search for
alternative Pathways to security and
fulfillment right sounds familiar to a
lot of crypto people because I think
that many of us actually share the exact
same skepticism toward systems right uh
in addition what's going on with people
that have this view of the world is that
they have this very shortterm mindset uh
and where that's come where that's
coming from uh is from the fact that
they think that there's no solid
foundation to trust long term if there's
nothing you know meaningful in the long
term of course you know I'm just going
to be flipping coins like you know day
by day and moving from the one project
to the another nothing matters right so
in finance this frequently manifest on
hyp speculation um selfishness at the
core and then fundamentally like nothing
to believe in as you can see this is not
um just specific to our industry uh but
it has found a great home in our
industry uh what's interesting is that
the same you know like like loss of
trust Faith skepticism towards
traditional uh systems we share that I
identify with that statement but I feel
that like what a lot of the builders
within the ethereum space try to do is
they try to build an alternative rather
than actually say you know Screw
everything you know everything sucks
everything is a pony you know nothing is
worth doing anything right but while I
feel that you know within the ethereum
developer Community we do a lot of that
uh I think that has still failed to
translate outside of the crypto
community so outside of the crypto
Community um we struggle to show many
use cases over time uh that go beyond
speculation right the dominant view here
is that okay you have the speculative
stuff and then you have some other
things that come and go you know and
like I feel that we really have failed
to to to to show um in in an engaging
and retaining way um this this this
promise of the space and in addition you
know we have other sit here which is
like you know D is now trendy here right
like is this great no it's not I think
it's actually quite problematic and it's
quite problematic to a lot of you know
young developers that actually don't
have all the the historical background
but these are you know all of those
things create this imbalance in
perception and culture and I really
think that this is actually is is
hurting our
space and the interesting thing is that
every cycle it gets worse right like you
know 2017 we had icos probably better
than 2021 we had you know many sketchy
nft projects and this cycle uh
apparently it's all about mem coins and
I'll say this up front this isn't the
talk where it says mecoin mem coins bad
don't touch them absolutely not uh but
out of curiosity like how many of you
are holding a Bitcoin can you raise your
hand okay how many of you have traded a
mcoin at some point in your life okay
almost half of the room and how many of
you have profited from a mcoin even just
slightly bit same okay very interesting
I think this this demonstr the point U
MIM coins do not per se mean Financial
nihilism and I I want to clearly
demonstrate that point but because I
think it's subtle um the good case of
mcoins of course is that you know it's
about a good laugh right like it's about
having fun it's about getting creative
with visuals uh it's it's a you to
the status quo many times or as we saw
with the recent elections it's it's a
commentary on the state of things and
many times these things actually come
even above profit there's there's some
noise
yes do you want to uh should I replace
this one okay sounds
good sorry for that uh that will
eliminate the that will eliminate the
noise we have so yeah so back back to
mem coins uh so mcoins the the good case
right so so the good case is is is a lot
more things rather than just profit many
times it creates this sense of belonging
and Collective identity connecting
people across different backgr and and
geographies right and sometimes you even
might make some money as as like you
know clearly this like quick Guerilla
survey that we just did here
demonstrates uh but but unfortunately I
think that you know the use cases we've
seen are still very few where that is
what's happening um on the other side
the Bad Case MIM coins usually translate
into hyper gambling right and um many
times you know they try to present these
projects as fair games in comparison to
you know every other Pony in crypto
right uh but many times these games are
actually rigged at their core and they
masquerading as Fair um and you know we
can even go further right like you know
I'm wondering many times is this what
community can be uh but I don't want to
make a moral judgment on that one but
you know fundamentally many of these
cases leave you with like more
loneliness more selfishness and and and
more
trouble and you know if you think about
where we are like uh you probably have
seen this uh you know right now there's
like a dominant investment thesis even
about the mcoin super cycle right and uh
this is this is uh from a a a talk from
a investor and Trader called Murad
mahmudov and he's making all sorts of
really interesting points if you haven't
seen that it's on YouTube I highly
recommend actually watching that talk
because he really touches on a lot of
interesting points I don't endorse or
believe many of the things that he says
but I think it's a very interesting
analysis of what's going on in that
space and why that uh mcoin super cycle
might be happening and um he's sharing
all sorts of interesting um reasons for
that he has a set of reasons that he
calls the internal to the crypto
industry like for instance you know
every vcoin is launching in basilon
valuations so of course you know mcoins
appear to be a lot more fair right and
things like that uh but additionally has
a lot of external Illusions which I I
find very interesting and some of the
things that he says is that you know you
have accelerated prices of everyday
Goods right you have the fear of ai ai
is here to take your jobs go gamble you
know uh you have like you know wealth
and income in inequality um and many
more things which all fundamentally lead
down to this idea of like you know
crisis of
meaning and the thing that I start to
think especially as it appears that we
entering another bull cycle is that if
Murad is right then we are indeed
entering in a mcoin super cycle I don't
think that again we're ready for this
we're just going to have another another
um cycle like you know 2021 where we're
going to suffer again to Showcase what
what what what crypto could be Beyond
just the speculative use case uh this is
this is a belief uh from some of my
friends at ferse that actually I think
went went quite viral a few weeks ago we
can remain Cipher Banks longer that they
can remain dent
I start to challenge that I'm actually
you know losing hope uh on on on this
specific thing in fact what I see is
that even in our own circles I feel that
you know the markets are absorbing us
faster than we can provide an
alternative um and I want to stay
positive so yeah um I've seen seen a lot
of friends you know that went uh from
you know interesting thinkers promising
actually into like PVP sealers and yeah
YOLO right um yeah something is
problematic here and we even keep
telling ourselves even more funny
stories about that stuff it's great we
stress testing this infrastructure right
like this infrastructure is so tested
now because of all of those meme coins
we've seen and good examples will come
and you know many times I feel like the
people that dropping the the the good
examples will come keep pointing at
vitalic basically redistributing many of
the meme coins that people send to him
right uh but you know that's not
scalable that's not sustainable uh and
of course you know it's a wider
phenomenon not specific to our industry
so let's keep closing our
eyes um so all of that makes me think
that actually there are um conflicting
cultures in crypto I think we are at
this point in time um and there are many
reasons for that but I think it's
important that we get to recognize that
and we as developers actually start to
get a lot more strategic with regards to
the type of messaging uh that we want to
commun Comm unicate I think what's going
on is actually described really nicely
by vitalic this is one of his uh older
posts I think earlier earlier this year
or later in 2023 where what he tries to
do is that he tries to outline the
different actors within the crypto
ecosystem and their motivations and you
see clearly here that you have uh the
builders right then you have the token
holders and the defi users this at the
moment is heavily skewed towards you you
know the DJ Vibes uh that you know the
after number go up many times at the at
the expense of a lot of other things and
then the interesting thing from that is
that you have he has this this bottom
this box here the pragmatic users and I
feel that this is almost the core of it
um what has happened is that we have
priced out all of those pragmatic users
right most of them for a long time they
couldn't use ethereum Manet so ethereum
Manet was not for them so what happened
is that you left with the builders and
then then you you you left with the Deen
and I think you know somewhere there
there's also a bit of a
class so there's a lot more that you
know on the criticisms uh I'm not going
to go through all of them uh this is
another common one scammers Paradise I'm
a developer and still you know worried
to actually interact with many of those
DBS uh there's a lot more to that
there's like ethereum as Mas creating as
decentralization I don't believe that
but I think some of the trade-offs we
made collectively in the past with
regards to bringing this infrastructure
to the world are now kind of biting us
um um plus many other things that
actually are happening on on the Dow
space but I want to leave at least a few
minutes and you know give you some
positive stuff right so what can we do
about it uh this isn't you know a talk
that tries to depress you um so as I
said before I think this whole idea
about financial nihilism goes down to a
crisis of meaning so I think
fundamentally what we have to do we have
to actually give people Something to
Believe In and not just give them show
them the thing it's not about talk
anymore right like we've been building
for a while so we need to show them
actually uh what What's possible and I
think you know the the the the the the
the foundation for that actually lies
within Cypher Punk and and and force
culture right again Cypher punks
actually believed in something they
believed in in in individual freedom and
they believed in empowering individual
in an increasingly authoritarian world
right it wasn't about nothing and it
wasn't about hypers speculation in fact
most of them were actually highly
skeptical about that right um and I
think I think vitalic does a really good
job of outlining values that we need to
start again you know go back to those
routs and think about open and Global
participation what is it that we have to
say about that right sensive resistance
or datability credible credible
neutrality and and and a lot more um and
most importantly I think we need to stop
this like I think like we're
educating people that dig and equal
Cypher Punk but has nothing to do with
each other like and I think it's
important that you know we call it out
what it is I'm not calling for any
censorship absolutely no ethereum should
remain neutral infrastructure but I
think we should also you know start
telling the story that that you know we
we believe
in so I wanted to close with a few more
ideas that actually we hear from
Builders uh some of the positive stuff
some of the positive narratives one of
the most surprising things to me is that
how powerful this idea Still Remains
eight years later like we talked to
builders and they were like oh etherum
the world computer that was exciting but
it didn't happen somehow right and I
feel that we actually quite close um you
know uh this is from Gavin Wood's
presentation back in the day uh about
that but back back then you know we
described ethereum as the stack of
different Technologies and we actually
quite close to having many solutions
there we can think of ethereum as a
stack we just need to tell that
story um same story um ethereum as an
alternative to Big Tech that excites
developers I can tell you that people
are super excited about that but again
we're failing on them every solution
we're building is kind of p on AWS and
you know Google cloud and call it right
uh but I think luckily some people start
to organize and I heard that yesterday I
wasn't here but there was a massive uh
ethereum Cipher Bank Gathering and now
they're producing this great ethereum
cyberpank starter kit which actually
starts to look like a stack starts to
look like you know a bunch of readings
uh it's a it's a great starting point
and shout out to the web through privacy
uh crew that uh is pushing all of that I
think it's more needed now than ever um
and then finally privacy um we like
globally um yeah we are in in Peculiar
uh we entering peculiar times uh privacy
is more important now than ever um so
yeah I think we should have something to
say about that
right uh so yeah so finally some more
ideas uh smaller uh but developer events
should focus on our Northstar I think
Devcon this year they're doing a great
job on that so shout out to the
organizers I really feel that we making
progress on that I really think that
developer event should be more about so
now less tell and I know that I'm giving
you a tell today but uh hey uh
additionally I think that we should have
a lot more dog fooding there's a lot of
technology that we're building but we
actually as the ethereum community we're
not supporting that we're going for the
convenient solution you know maybe we
should take these things a little bit
more seriously and then finally we
should we should set a higher technical
standard with regards to our values and
principles um and we should do all of
those things while keeping ethereum the
tech stack as neutral infrastructure uh
that's all I had um thank you so much
thank you very much it was yeah super
nice to hear uh your view of both
cultures and also kind of interesting to
see how many sort of meme coin Deens are
amongst us are you one yeah yeah me too
I'm sorry I
apologize I was feeling really bad I
didn't put my hand up but um yeah I
mean yeah we make the excuses anyway um
we go to the questions um so there's
just one so far I also have many but if
you want to add more we have four
minutes so
now's your chance um I think you touched
on this a little bit in the talk but um
one of the questions was is it ethical
to build apps that harness Degen greed
to fund public goods does the end
justify the means yeah I mean it's a
great question I'm not uh I think making
moral judgments is is is a tricky thing
um so I think it's a it's a question
that the person that wrote it needs to
answer it for themselves and then act
accordingly uh I believe in the values
of ethereum and that's why in my
presentation actually I continue to say
that you know neutral infrastructure is
the foundation for all of those things
but I think additionally now we need to
act and then we need to be a lot more
tactical with regards to um our
Communications so yeah not I don't have
an answer for you I think this is a
personal answer that you based on your
morals you need to answer I think you
made a comment during the talk actually
that I sort of latched on to that I
liked and this was um about ballic
donating m coins or whatever and you
said it's not scalable I think that can
also apply here it's like okay fine you
can build apps that you can dejen on to
fund public goods but like probably only
you are going to do that or like you and
the few friends around you like so it's
probably not so scalable and then you
know by doing that you sort of encourag
this uh yeah no totally I think beyond
what you say and I agree with what you
say uh the other interesting thing
that's happening is that it feels like
the dent crowd is already looking
elsewhere right they are in blockchains
and you know they now many of them start
to look elsewhere the reason for that is
that what ethereum provides is quite
different right if you're all after like
speed and you know SQL database and
something that is handwavy decentralized
well you know maybe this is not the
place and I think many for many of the
you know mcoin D the the nists not all
of them again as I communicate in my
presentation um yeah that might be a
better place
good okay um so maybe like we have
another two minutes left one of my kind
of things is like there is a bit of a
push in this Cypher Punk community and
like the fast mindset and like even
within the Privacy Technologies you
start to see um some projects or
companies being a little bit criticized
for not being like fully open source or
having some licensing or whatever do you
see this as like yeah basic Bally like
why do you see the community sort of
like becoming so strong now like is it
yeah was there a particular event or
yeah do you have anything to say about
this like the good Tech that you want to
see but maybe isn't fully fast as well
two questions yeah yeah the the first
part of your question I think I think
what's happening is that you have this
increased monopolization of the internet
right you have the cloud Wars and many
of the the conversations the open source
Community the last few years had with
regards to licenses is this open source
is this somehow open source and all of
that they are a product of that thing
right basically what you have now is you
have these aggressive players that
actually go and deploy a service of your
open source thing and then the open
source developers are left in a really
weird position where they thought that
they can make the sustainable but now
actually they clearly can't because they
competing against some of the most um
well financed uh companies on the planet
so I I think that the answer to this is
again new business models new value
flows for um open source software and
some of those Technologies and it
continues to be one of the things that
excites me the most about the space
right is this whole public goods funding
space um I think we made some
progress I think you know there's a lot
more to be done there but I think
fundamental is about that it's about
actually providing an alternative to
those developers versus actually having
to make those many times questionable
decisions with regards to licensing and
and yeah make those funny moves
basically well I think we're right on
time but I think this is a nice point to
end it on and like I think if anybody
can actually you know make the progress
in the right direction it's exactly the
cipher fun Community who does have a bit
of a I don't know like nicer not nicer
way of thinking I'm being showing my
preferences now but like you know
honest ways of thinking maybe rational
ways of thinking so um it feels like a
much more Progressive way of thinking to
me so it feels like this is where
progress can be made so anyway hopefully
we thank the speaker again and uh we
take a five minute break before or three
minute break sorry uh before the next
session thank you thank you very much
[Music]
in
for
[Music]
[Applause]
hello um welcome back for the last
session in the cypherpunk and privacy
truck I feel like I'm actually getting
into the MC thing after three hours but
yeah we're getting going so for the last
session we will have two speakers give
us a bit of an overview about privacy
and digital identity and I think this is
something that probably everyone in this
room has thought about and has worried
about at some point because I think a
lot of people's these privacy conscious
people feel a little bit bad about web 3
in the sense that they lose privacy
relative to web 2 and this feels kind of
wrong and then also at the same time you
have like all of your sort of activity
tied to a particular identity and this
feels even wrong wor more wrong so uh
yeah there's a lot to kind of reconcile
there and so um yeah I'm very curious to
hear about um yeah privacy digital
identity and how to avoid uh dystopia
basically so yeah give it up for the two
speakers thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody I'm Jord valina Sasha
from priv ID um what's digital identity
to make it easy digital identity is when
you sign in to a page actually you're
using your your digital uh identity
currently digital identity is uh
controlled by very few corporations here
Facebook Twitter and so on just a side
note uh here in the web three it's not
even governed by governments I mean
governments here could be a good allies
to uh Implement self Sovereign identity
because probably the governments they
don't want to uh uh give the identity to
these big corporations so it's very it's
fragmented I mean it's not very
fragmented but I mean There is five four
five six seven
uh big corporations that holds most of
the people's uh identity and this
fragmentation and other things that
gives us a really bad ux I mean I'm sure
that maybe not here but in a lot of uh a
lot of users has problems with passwords
and managing passwords managing uh
connections uh emails and all these kind
of uh digital identity so when we when
we go to web three and we are building
DBS actually we need identity too I mean
we have the two exceptions I mean when
you are transferring funds maybe you
don't need an identity you just well you
need a you have some sort of identity
which is an account but you don't really
need identity but if you want to do any
other application I don't know voting or
you want to do um I mean you want to
connect to a or something you will need
some sort uh of login I mean you need
some sort of identity so we need
identity in the web three and when we go
to Identity with web
three we may end up doing uh very much
the same I mean if this is controlled by
very few corporations
then what is happening is that even more
fragmented and the ux is even even worse
so and not only that I mean the digit
the when we go to the cites there are
other risks and other important things
that are happening of course we have the
the the Privacy thing if we are
publishing data this this data can be
leakage easily and there are a lot of
challenge that we need to uh solve on
that
so how this solution needs to be of
course needs to be self Sovereign I mean
needs to be the centralizes each one
needs to hold the the their own identity
and you are kind of a server of your
identity I mean you you you are the the
identity
uh the protocol privacy needs to be by
by default and by Design I mean privacy
needs to be here is where zero knowledge
is important I mean the centralite
identity without zero knowledge is
impossible to to make here I want to do
a a note and is that the zero knowledge
technology has been evolved a lot if you
in the last in the last years if you if
you just go back three years ago uh it
was difficult to build identity systems
because you end up using your own
cryptography you end up using um I mean
you had to do identity but in a specific
way so that you can apply zero knowledge
currently the zero knowledge technology
and thank you to all these uh layer
tools and all these Evolution that
happens in the last year it's it's much
more powerful much more faster and it's
perfectly possible to use normal
cryptography that means that you can use
current attestations I mean the when the
the signatures of of the governments the
signatures of the organizations that are
already happening so a lot of
attestations real attestations that are
actually happen you can use them in zero
knowledge so you can build these
decentralized database of that
attestation it's a single database where
everybody just uh Shar
just have access to a small part of that
and then you can single source of Truth
and then you can prove things uh around
that and finally of course this needs to
be a open standard simple standard it
will not can for big corporations it
will come from The Roots it will come
from the like dcpip I mean this needs to
be something that should be uh simple so
as an example of how to connect this uh
identity to this uh uh to this uh identi
so to these signatures to these
attestations that already happen in the
world uh I'm going to give the the word
to to Sasha that will explain the word
that we are doing in uh prad ID Sasha
thank
you thank you Jordan
so yeah what what's prad ID Prado ID is
a self- sovereign identity solution but
also it's a middleware it's it's an
infrastructure so that you are able to
build your own applications that are um
that have identity that can work on
different chains multiple devices and um
it's based on um industry standards it's
based on
w3c dads and verifiable credentials so
it's a um interoperable system that
you're able ble to to use and build on
top of it and also
it's it's powered by zero knowledge
proofs so whenever you are using it
you're not sharing your actual data
you're sharing only proof that you're
eligible to do something like you're
over 18 to purchase liquor in the store
yeah without providing whole document
without sharing your picture without
sharing your the actual date of birth
your passport number and so
on and key
features that we have is that we are
unifying um this fragmented identity we
are bringing all different chains
together we are making it work on
different multiple devices at the same
time and also we are unifying web 2 and
web 3 system
so it's usable uh on D apps and on your
regular applications and also on like
regular stores where you would go and
buy things of chain
offline
and
um very important
that for many things you need to do it
only once like if you go and ask keyway
you would do it only once then your
credentials your um data would be stored
on your device under your control and
you would be sharing some pieces of it
uh on on
request you would be sharing just proofs
for example that you're over 18 as I
said or maybe for for some cases you
would be selectively disclosing some
data maybe it would be a uh for for
example seat number in in your ticket
credential let's say yeah something like
that
and we have two other very important
features and very useful one is privacy
preserving proof of uniqueness and
another decentralized trustless
issuance where smart contract is issuing
you credentials so that's why it could
be um TR Less in terms that you are not
trusting any specific centralized
authority to issue your credential you
can do it on on chain in a decentralized
manner but also it could be done in
privacy preserving
manner so what's how how it's working
this proof of uniqueness that that we
have it's um based on credentials
it could be different kinds of
credentials it could be yeah it could be
biometrical data yeah but also it could
be like phone number or credential that
you uh have from your uh employer that
your employee and then you can use it to
do for example voting in a
company um Anonymous survey
without disclosing who you are and
without doing your iris SC to prove that
you're unique yeah uh employer already
knows that you're unique you it can
control this data and issue you
credential and then you are able to to
use it to prove uniqueness uh without
disclosing who you actually are and do
specific action only once like voting
and it's not only limited to um by
credential so you you you can use it uh
on on a specific credential for for
specific use case but also we have um
special way to distinguish between
different sessions even inside um one
application for example if you're doing
multiple
votings um or multiple Surs then you can
um give a different contexts um for the
user and um nullifier your unique
identifier for for this purpose would be
different between uh each session so
that you would
be anonymous you you would not be it
would not be possible to track um who is
actually um voting between these
different
sessions and as I said there is
different use cases you can use it even
for um Nationwide voting for example it
could be biometrical based on
biometrical document uh like um atar
card and then you would prove that
you're unique and you're eligible to
vote and count this vote only once
and decentralized Trust trustless
issuance is a feature that allows you to
to do this in a privacy preserving
manner so that even there is no
centralized issuer that knows who you
are so that issuer would be able to
track who is it acting um and um
possibly de anonymize you
so now I will show you how how it
works and first demo is just a simple
very very simple uh application where
you are able to prove that you your
ownership of etherium address so you
would receive a credential that you're
owner of AUM address
okay so what what you need to do is
actually you you're just authenticating
uh
to uh the system and then you send a
transaction
and that's it credential is issued data
was already on chain so nothing needs to
be additionally proven so it's it's very
simple and voila you have a credential
in the same way we can do balance
credential proof of ownership of nft or
um any data that is available on
chain and now I will show you demo of
how it works with um at hard cart so we
have integration with uh project by PC
uh Anon
atar and and
um big thanks to to yanis from Anar who
helped us and build first proof of
concept and we are now iterating over it
and um improving to to embedd it into
our uh
solution so what is happening now is
that
um maybe some of you had uh interacted
with Anar to to get a cheaper ticket to
Devcon so you would essentially scan a c
code from
atar and this uh C code leads to to your
data that is stored on um government
website that is fetched uh to you and
then zero knowledge circuit uh is
running on your side and verifies that
this data is correct
and issues your
credential so this credential it's it's
uh on your device actual data is not
leaving your device it's it's it's there
and zero knowledge proof is uh generated
on on your device not on some server or
or issuer
software and yeah and that's how it
works so you you receive a credential
and uh initial generation
takes a bit more time but later you can
use it uh very quickly and and
easily and that's how how you can create
a query to to this credential and use it
for for for example for voting yeah so
in this example I'm creating a request
to prove that you're over 18 and that
you are a unique person based on Unown
at hard
credential I need to fill a few
Fields including uh identifier of the
isser and
then we see wallet interface so prev
previously I was showing you Mobile
Wallet
interface and uh right now just because
we have a Multi-Device experience if you
have um created your wallet with the
same AUM address then you can use it on
mobile but also in the
web so you you are
generating proof based on that
credential that you have received and
Ola um you proved that you are over 18
and that you're unique user based on
your uh Anonymous atar
credential thank
you thank you very much uh for giving us
yeah a tour of digital identity I'll get
you to stand over here and uh we can go
into the Q so there were quite a few
questions um so we can yeah take a look
at them here so with Selective
disclosure how do you prevent abuses
from Services asking you to share all
your data even if they don't need
everything so yeah like I think the
example with the passport is a nice one
why not just say like okay so what's
your passport number and your date of
birth and your first name and your last
name and the code everything like this
so how do you prevent this this is this
is more a challenge of a UI that than uh
actually technical all the data is yours
so at the end because you are holding
the data here is you I mean you are
going to give the data only if they ask
to you here is more about the the wallet
and so you hold data and it's about the
UI that ensures that so that interprets
the query that they are doing and tells
very clear to the user exactly what
information they are giving here again
this is not easy it's a you U is a UI ux
uh challenge here of course a lot of uh
social hacking can be uh but and that's
something that's relatively new because
I mean we are users we are not used to
whole data in general and uh but this is
something that here UI I mean it's a lot
of work here in in in in priv ID with
developing the wallet we having working
really hard on on on on this front and I
tell you that's not uh not easy there is
but there is there are ways that uh a
lot of things that can be improved and
there are ways to to do this to do these
things maybe you can warn the users like
uh you're going You're about to leak
everything if you uh if you if you allow
this uh cool so er another question if
we want to apply this at organization
level can we have shared verifiable
credentials among multiple organization
members right now we do not support
support um identities for organizations
but we are working on this we we have a
few ideas how to implement this and that
would be in future releases yes nice but
what what's clear is that I mean and
this is the thing I mean the identity is
one and then can be many organizations
that can do claims on your same identity
and uh the other thing is so this is and
this is the way to go so it's like and
have like many claims doing working in
your identity even as identity you can
do even claims which is something that
in the in the in the Legacy world is not
doesn't even used to happen there is a
lot of things I mean all the
interactions that the humans are doing
uh say serious interactions they can be
converted to a claim I mean anything
that you are do you are accessing to a
web page you can have a claim on that I
mean everything can be converted to a
claim and then you can prove you can use
that to prove something you can put that
in a database and do a query on this
database and you can prove that I don't
know you access 10 times this web page
in the last month and you can do these
things like that yeah have different
like tokens and things I me they do this
sometimes uh so how does it work if I
lose access to the keys can I export
them yeah basically you need to Pi up
your keys
yes but um what we are trying to solve
right now is for to to be able to on
board web to users we need something
that is not key based like we we need a
social social login or this kind of um
login systems to work with your identity
and we are working on enabling users to
control their identity with regular uh
existing web to login systems yes is
important to to to mention that
U sing means that you are holding your
keys okay maybe you want to delegate
this um keeping to somebody else but the
first thing is that you you should be
able to choose that's the first the
first thing okay so that's that would
say the first condition but even that
here requires a lot of uh educ education
this very much like holding the keys of
your ethereum wallet I mean you need to
be responsible so here there is a lot of
usage uh learnings in there social
recovery is the the other point which is
also an interesting topic uh yeah but
this is way to go is in that direction
yeah so I also saw some other yeah like
CK email things like this are doing like
the account recovery and all sorts of
interesting privacy preserving is ways
of doing maybe you don't do it for like
your your millions of Bitcoin that you
hold but like for other accounts I think
it can be
good uh we still have another minute or
two so we can go through another
question if you're happy to uh how does
it work oh I'm sorry if so how does it
compare to World ID does it also use
semaphor uh it's it's different we are
not using semaphor um but it's also
based on Merkle trees um just like semor
is a is a Merkle tree uh essentially but
we are using uh it a bit differently and
um yeah we we I think the the biggest uh
difference is
that compared to World ID we have many
issues we support all VM chains natively
you just need to deploy a smart contract
and then you would be able to verify
proofs and uh we have all different
kinds of credentials not only your iris
data that somehow is stored on on their
side and and then you have a credential
that yeah I think this is a super
interesting point especially for like
the cipher Punk crowd who are the type
of community I think who does like to
reason between these different types of
because I think it's quite important
Point actually that yeah there are
multiple issuers and like I mean how
like there are different ways to do
things and like which is good for your
application or another and it's yeah
it's good seor is a good example of this
Legacy days where you need to use a
specific cryptography to do a identity
the cool thing now is that you can
connect to semaphore for example I mean
of course you need to implement it and
maybe it's not worthy but you can
connect to semaphore the same way that
you can connect to the uh uh to the
government provider or a passport or a
email from some place or or even I mean
you can connect to different sources of
attestations including semaphor I mean
it's not an exception uh in order to
have a claim in order to use this claim
in order to build a proof that you want
to prove something you could prove that
you have uh some account in semafor and
maybe a government ID and you can put
that in the same circuit and this is the
the this and this is possible thank you
to zero knowledge this is this is what
it's happening right now I love it very
cool well that's the that's all we've
got time for but yeah thank you for
being the final talk in the uh Cipher
Punk and privacy session today uh thank
you very much again if you'd like to
thank the
speakers um so uh yeah that's it for us
so we have a five minute break now to do
a bit of a switch over uh we'll come
back at uh 4:30 I've lost track of
whatever hour it is we'll be back at
4:30 with the applied crypto truck see
you in a few minutes thank you
[Music]
for
hello and welcome back to the last
session of the day which is on applied
crypto and I'm super excited to see
what's going on so after the last
session if anyone of you was still there
we had privacy and Cipher Punk for the
last few hours and we talked a lot about
how maybe it's not so necessary to
actually fully understand all the crypto
because there's like a whole bunch of
stuff around the crypto that you need to
do to make privacy apps and things like
that but I think if you do want to
really kind of think about privacy apps
and reason about them and reason about
the security and the type of things that
you're trying to build it is important
to know some cryptography so I think
we're in for a treat where we can get a
little introduction a beginner's view of
cryptography old and new with uh ining
Tong and Tyler so thank you very much
give them a round of applause and uh
scan the QR codes ask lots of questions
upvote them and yeah I'll see you in a
few minutes welcome
[Music]
thank hey I'm Tyler I go by at heart
engineer on the internet and this is
ying Tong um so I'm an engineer she's a
cryptographer so we're going to kind of
go back and forth between uh the
mathematical View and then like the
Layman's explanations for a lot of uh
introductory
cryptography so cryptography really is
kind of a blend of Art and Science and
it's the art and sights of
Secrets um all right Yep this one's you
yeah and often times we think of the
purpose of a cryptographic system in
terms of um these three properties CIA
um so firstly
confidentiality um the property of
keeping your messages secret and
ensuring that they're only ever read by
their intended
recipient Integrity um being assured
that the message message at the time of
reading has not been tampered with um
from the time of
sending and authenticity that the
message was indeed uh sent by the
expected sender and not forged um by
someone else so a cryptographic system
should provide
Assurance of these three
properties so this really comes down to
uh you basically have these puzzles that
are very easy to solve if you have the
right key and very hard to solve if you
don't have the key uh there's a little
note at the bottom there's a lot of
nuance here this is very hand wavy
you're G to hang out on this side
okay um but yeah so easy to solve with a
key if you don't have the key very very
hard so the topics we're going to go
over are hashing encryption signing and
what we're now calling programmable
cryptography which is ZK MPC and fhe and
you can kind of think of this breakdown
as corresponding to the three properties
that we discussed just now so hashing is
a primitive that's often used um to
provide Integrity assurances of
Integrity um encryption helps us to
preserve
confidentiality and signing is a way to
provide
authenticity um and these three former
Primitives and Protocols are what we
consider first generation cryptography
in the sense that they're purpose built
for a specific protocol um and um in the
rest of Devcon on the applied
cryptography track you're going to hear
a lot more about programmable
cryptography um which usually involve
more heavy weight and more general
purpose protocols
all right so hashing is a one-way
function that basically gives you a
fingerprint of some
data you can think of this as just this
magic machine that you put data in one
side and then that fingerprint comes out
the other side so this is an example of
what that machine looks like which is
pretty gnarly but essentially it comes
down to you put in you know for example
a password it gets hashed and then some
fingerprint comes out the other
side um oh
Sil um this a good analogy for this is
like uh blending fruits in a blender
right like you can't get the fruits back
out but you have a consistent like color
right if you add just bananas in you're
going to get the same color basically
every time um so unique input unique
output these are always fixed length so
that's to stop certain types of attacks
where you can try to like infer what
kind of data went in and you can see so
hi hell help and hello like they have
very similar letters but they're totally
different
fingerprints you want to talk about this
yeah so we've put in sort of Snippets of
the relevant Devcon talks um throughout
our slides to help you Orient um and
actually um oh this talk already
happened but it was an example of how
you can build a general purpose proof
system just using hash function as a
primitive so you can go back and watch
this talk you can do a lot with hash
functions cool so a common reason that
hash functions are used is passwords but
as you can see if two users had the same
password they have the same password
hash right so this allows an attack
called a like rainbow table attack
basically you just hash like all comment
passwords and then now you have this
known fingerprint and you can you know
use that to attack people's passwords
but there's this thing called assault
you can add which is essentially just
tacking a random string that's specific
to each user to the end of the password
and then hashing it now you have a
unique fingerprint for every password
hash so this is just like a example of
how um hashing is used very commonly so
pretty much every popular website that
has logins uses uh bcrypt with per user
salts like this is a pretty pretty
common
technique all right this is all you yeah
and I think hash functions are a great
introduction um as a cryptographic
primitive because they seem very simple
the API is really straightforward but a
cryptographic hash function actually has
to fulfill a few
properties um so we won't go over them
in detail but
um I think I put this in to highlight
also that there exist non- cryptographic
hash functions so um that are way more
efficient than cryptographic hash
functions and that are suitable
for um use cases such as hash tables
which are not um sort of high security
so in hash tables for instance we don't
need um the Collision resistance
property in fact in hash tables we have
many um techniques to handle collisions
buckets um so and at the same time um
cryptographic security of a hash
function is I think literally defined as
um for how long has this hash function
remained unbroken for um and the that's
that's where the art of cryptography
comes in um Crypt analysis security
analysis um and reasoning about the
cryptographic security of a certain
primitive so yeah hash functions we
chose to as an introductory
primitive um just to give you a taste of
what they can be used for um how we
reason about them um
yeah another very common use case is in
Merkel trees I'm sure we're all familiar
um it's used in git
to produce unique digests of a a
repository um it's used in blockchains
um
to produce L cryptographically linked
headers from block to block um for
instance in the ethereum state
all right so now we're going to go over
encryption real quick um so one of the
original like encryption algorithms that
were used it's called a Caesar Cipher
and it's terrible um but basically you
take the alphabet and you shift it by
you know some number and let's say if we
want to write hello you're going to
identify those letters and then
basically just
translate to the new code right um and
if you want to reverse it you basically
just shift it the other way and then you
get the original message back out uh
this is
4.6 bits of security so basically 26
letters minus one and it's terrible um
we have much much better techniques
nowadays um so symmetric key encryption
which is basically what you know a
Caesar cyer is a type of symmetric key
encryption um but it's when all the
parties that are participating have the
same key right so use the same key to
encrypt and decrypt uh there's 's no
authentication so you don't know who
encrypted the message um and basically
anyone with a key can decrypt it but it
is fast and it's used very commonly with
like data at rest or TLS stuff like that
stuff where you need like high bandwidth
uh common examples AES for like an
actual algorithm that's
used all right so yeah secret key plain
text to go in you get some Cipher text
out to decrypt you put in a secret keyy
in your Cipher text you have a decrypt
function and then you get your plain
text back
out all
right um yeah and
um yeah so symmetric encryption is
suitable for when both parties are able
to establish a common shared secret um
and to use it both to encrypt and to
decrypt but in many use cases we want
the ability to say asynchronously and
non inter inter actively encrypt a
message to a recipient and in this case
um asymmetric encryption comes in really
handy because all you need to know is
the public key of your recipient and
they can decrypt the message at any time
they want without um without your help
so we put the API here I think what's
important to note that's different um
from symmetric encryption is that the
encryption and decryption keys are
different and the in
particular um when we encrypt um we H
when we encrypt we don't need any
privileged information um and when we
decrypt we need a private key that
should absolutely stay
secret um so a very closely related
primitive in public key cryptography is
signatures and you can think of a
signature as a sort of Watermark so the
API changes slightly um in this case um
we're using a private key to sign a
message and using the public key to
verify um that it was indeed signed by
who we expected so it's really
interesting um for example like the same
crypto system RSA can be used for both
encryption and signing and often times
well and it just involves flipping
actually which key you use um so I think
something to note here is that um let's
say in RSA to verify um a signature
you're actually you actually decrypted
um using one of the RS a key Pairs and
um this means that anyone can read the
signed message so it's not this it does
not give you the same um properties of
cont confidentiality but it does give
you uh authentic
authenticity um and you can look out for
oh this talk already ended but in
ethereum um they're currently using a
signature scheme that is not postquantum
secure and they're actively um thinking
about how to
transition uh to postquantum
yeah so a common Paradigm in like email
for example is used uh like used signing
and encryption right so you want to be
able to prove that you're the one that
created the message and you only want
the recipient to be able to read it so
in order to do this you would put in
your private key in a message you would
sign the message and you would take that
signed message take the other party's
public key and encrypt the message and
then send it to them so they can take
that decrypt it and then also verify
that you or the
sender all right so https everyone knows
what this is this little green lock you
know make sure you're you have a secure
connection to the server um this is a
little hand wavy but uh the general
explanation is if you connect to a
server you do this key exchange it's
called Diffy Helman which I'll go into
in the next slide and you get out a
symmetric key right so public key
cryptography is slow compared to
symmetric key
so um yeah basically to to make web
pages load faster you would do this
Diffy Helman key exchange and then get
out a symmetric key that only you and
the server know and then from there on
you can do um faster messages so the way
this works is you start with some shared
paint right some shared colors and this
is the paint analogy for for DIY helmet
but you start with some shared paint and
then you each have some secret color and
you combine those to create these two
inputs you exchange the inputs you add
back in your secrets and then you end up
with the same paint color on either side
but no one in the middle could know what
your what your secrets
are yeah so um we went through hashing
encryption and signatures um and we
we're considering these to be sort of
generation one purpose-built
cryptography that are really lightweight
and um just do their task really well um
what's been emerging um and what you'll
see a lot of Devcon is programmable
cryptography so um these include zero
knowledge proofs um multi-party
computation and fully homomorphic
encryption and these Protocols are
a lot more heavyweight in the sense that
they involve usually lots more um
assumptions security
exemptions um but on the other hand
they're a lot more general purpose in
the sense that the end user is free to
Define any arbitrary relation uh they're
not um limited to say signatures and
encryption um and in that sense um this
Clause of primitive are
programmable yeah I think these talks
happened
already um but introductions to this
Paradigm of programmable
cryptography so we'll quickly go through
the three categories um maybe the most
popular one is Zer knowledge
um yeah it's okay um so essentially zero
knowledge ZK is a way for a prover to
prove some statement to somebody else
and they can verify it so for example um
you can have your picture and then some
private data your age or your data birth
or whatever go into some ckp and then
out comes a hash of your photo and then
basically a thumbs up that you're like
over 21 or whatever um so you need that
hash of your photo to make sure that
someone can actually authenticate that
it's you they can they can see the image
make sure that it you know corresponds
with your age
um and yeah they can you know you can
prove your over 21 without showing your
license or your passport or
whatever yeah so the over 21 relation is
just one example of a relation that you
can prove in zero knowledge the point
here being that this is an arbitrary
user defined relation and as Tyler said
the pro can keep their secret witness um
unknown to the very verier and yet still
convinced the verifier that it satisfies
the relation um and corresponds to a
certain agreed upon and publicly known
output so another interesting property
of many zero knowledge proof systems is
sex synness and what this means is that
the prevere communication is much
smaller than the size of the relation
that he proved and this comes in handy
in ZK rollup which I think many of us
have heard about where whereby we
Outsource um very heavy computation to
some um well resourced Machine offchain
um and then simply submit a very small
proof of its validity on chain um the
point here being that verifying the
computation is a lot cheaper and we we
don't have to pay that much gas for it
um there's also many any other um sort
of developments in zero knowledge proof
systems um so I think youu actually will
talk about elliptic curves and snarks
right after us
um and many more exciting examples of um
applications that use ZK I think Prat
right before us for
example um so now if we sort
of
um if we introduce um this setting where
the witness is no longer held by a
single party namely the prer and we move
to consider like multiple parties um
working together to compete a relation
um this would bring us into um MPC
multi-party computation and um this is
is um a superet of zero knowledge
um um so it is a way for
multiple um parties to jointly compute a
function over secret inputs so yeah I
put this visual here to show that um
well once again we have an arbitrary
function um but what's changed is that
the the witness the secret input is now
split um across multiple
parties um and we can actually combine
um multiparty computation with Zer
knowledge proofs um and get um publicly
auditable NPC so we can have both an MPC
and a su synct certificate that the NPC
was done correctly um and you can Yeah
we actually have a bunch of NPC talks um
at this conference so yeah this ZK MPC
is what I was talking about publicly
auditable
MPC
um yeah so this is a project that uh our
colleague Andrew wrote so it's a game
where you can play Rock a modified
version of rock paper scissors over NPC
so only you and the person you're
playing with or like actually
participating there's no like
intermediate party and you can trust
that each other aren't cheating so fun
game right yeah and these are some other
applications of MPC that you can hear
about so the final sort of I think the
most heavyweight um um primitive in
programmable cryptography is fully
homomorphic encryption um and the API of
this looks pretty different so in this
case um
um the holder um of the secret data um
encrypts it homomorphically so it
transforms it um
into this sort of um Cipher text um that
preserves the privacy of the data but
also preserves the structure of it such
that any party um Can Transform it
according to any arbitrary function so
once again is fully programmable um but
all the work is kind of um outsourced um
to this arbitrary third party um so this
third party performs uh an arbitrary
computation and then returns
um uh so this third party is working
completely blindly um and ends up only
with a cipher text form of the output um
and the point here is is that only the
holder of the secret key um is able to
decrypt the output to some sensible
plain text
um and yeah there's actually been a
bunch of cool experiments using FH um by
cursive so you can check that out uh no
yeah that's already over as well um
so yeah I think that's all we have have
and do we have time for
questions
questions thank you first maybe give a
round of applause to the speakers for a
very nice overview of
cryptography um so it's a little bit
over time so we have maybe time for one
question but I think one that came in
very early and was uploaded a lot very
quickly was what are some good resources
to dive deeper into formal cryptography
as someone with no prior
experience so there is is a elliptic
curve cryptography primer by Cloud flare
that I would recommend um
it's a little long but it's very
understandable like you can you can get
through that pretty well um three blue
one brown did a video on how Bitcoin
works that he Dives deep and it's like
20 minutes and he he goes over uh
hashing and signing pretty deeply and
yeah I think those are probably two good
options oh also there's this legendary
cryptographer Dan Bonet who's done a
bunch of open courseware um courses with
like videos and course materials um I
think it's on corsera actually so I
highly highly recommend that
one cool I maybe watching back the talks
that you linked as well so watching the
videos back very nice so I think we're
at time we have a few minutes to switch
over for the next session but yeah we'
like to thank the speakers again and we
see you
so uh we'll be back in four minutes but
I was just advised to say there's quite
a lot of cans and stuff left around the
room if you don't mind just try and keep
things a little bit tidy thanks very
much see you in uh four minutes
[Music]
e
hello welcome back for the next session
in the applied crypto track so I think
we take a little bit of a tour uh Step
Beyond where we were in the last talk
and go we kind of uh zoom in on one of
the topics that was mentioned so in zero
knowledge and so yeah we'll zoom in to
Zer knowledge and snarks in particular
and get a view of what had happened in
the past and what has has happened in
the future so if you would like to give
a round of applause uh we welcome the
speaker thank
[Music]
you uh hi
everyone uh my name is uh
Yousef yeah so I'm a cryptographer at
consensus working on gnach the ZK Snak
library and Linea the ZK
evm um and today I'm going to talk about
elliptic on snacks so I have two
problems in my
life one getting my wife to choose a
restaurant difficult one and two
ethereum supports only bn25 for pre
compies so today I'm going to talk about
the second problem because the first one
we need more time
right uh so what are these BN 254
precompiled so BN 254 is a elliptic
curve so it is this mathematical objects
on which we can do some sort of
cryptography and mainly these operations
that we call pre-compile so they are
like native smart Contracting ethereum
so you can do addition like take two
points and add them have a third point
and you can do scalar multiplication
which is if you multiply a scalar by a
point so you get another point which is
like adding the points in times to
itself and the scalar and pairing
product check where you have some
bilinear map it takes points on eliptic
cures output them on some line some
extension field and multiply this and
check if it is one so I'm not going to
talk in details about these operations
but you can look at the illustrations
and pretend you got
it so what is most important is uh what
is it useful for so it is useful for
doing snug verification on ethereum
doing BLS signature verification on
ethereum like doing some polinomial
commitment like kcg verification on
ethereum and some vericle trees at least
with what we have for
now and uh uh so we've talked about B
and 250 254 as an elliptic curve but
there are so many elliptic Curves in the
wi and what I'm trying to explain today
is why there isn't like a single silver
silver bullet curve to them all so you
might have heard of bls2 381 SEC
p256 so used for ecdsa signature on eum
if you change a letter you have another
curve you might have heard of ed25519
some Two Chains some Cy like pasta
twiddle some fancier names like jbj
Bender snatch gram
King and some new names like lollipops
yeah so many
names so what I want to start with is
some definitions of what is past present
and future right so past are curves that
have been used in snarks but not anymore
present curves that that are still being
used in snars today and Future is cures
that already exist in the white but not
used in SNS just yet so if we follow
this colar scheme then yeah so we have
some green ones in the past like mnts or
twiddle cycle some blue like BLS or two
chains and some uh future purple like
lollipops and yeah you we see that BN is
half blue half green that is because it
is still using in ethereum but it's not
secure anymore or at least it doesn't
have the targ tared
security so uh to organize this mess I
uh propos to categorize it into three
columns so I'm calling non paing
friendly curves paing friendly curves
and in circuit curves so uh again this
pre compiles I talked about pairings but
not all the elliptic CS are equipped
with pairings or at least not
efficiently and if your snar doesn't
need pairings so you can use the cures
in the First Column if your snar needs
pairings then you need curves on the
second column and in circuit curves are
these kind of curves that were built in
purpose to do some computations over the
SN not to do the snar but just I don't
know you want to prove some signature
with a snar then maybe building an
efficient elliptic C would help you so
if we look uh if we take a closer look
to the First Column so we have for
example SNS like bulletproof or Halo or
Nova they can use the curves from the
first uh column but then the question is
why there isn't like a single curve well
it depends on what you want if you want
performance then maybe ed25519 is the
best curve if you want standard maybe
the next curve if you're scared of n
maybe you choose another standard like
Bitcoin or ethereum curve like sip if
you want a recursion that is you want to
do a proof of approve then maybe you can
use SQ if you want compatibility with
sigp if you do not care about compati
compatibility you just want performance
then twiddle if you want more
performance then pasta if if you want
hybrid recursion that is a snark from
the First Column and a snark in the
second column then maybe flute to Aries
or gkin BN if you want compatibility
with ethereum what about the second
column so the second column is for snars
that are pairing blazed those are like
go 16 or anything that is based on Kg
like plun for instance so you can use
any curve in the SEC in the second
column and then again why there isn't a
single curve if you want ethereum
compatibility then BN if you want
performance BL 12 if you want one
recursion that is a proof of approve
maybe you want to use two chains if you
want infinite recursion with paing base
so you have stuck with MES but these are
slow either slow or
unsecure if you at some hybrid recursion
then you can also have other uh
propositions here so the last colon is
so for example if you want to prove some
signatures like EDSA or ecdsa or some
specific hashes on sckers or some
vericle trees then you can choose from
this third colum but then again if you
want just elliptic curve cryptography
you might want to use jobjob if you want
faster tic cryptography may be Bender
snatch if you want paing based
cryptography then you need for example
two chains or Cycles then bw6 or MNT
either you want one recursion or
infinite recursion if you want to mix
things and make them sentous maybe the
lollipops if you want to make them
compatible with BN then maybe grk so
this is why we do not have like a single
elliptic curve but on ethereum we have a
single elliptic curve so what I want to
talk about next is The Story So Far
So gold Vasa mikal and ROV they invented
Zer knowledge fors and there have been a
lot of papers both on the Practical side
and the theoretical side
since yeah a lot but what I want to
focus on is pairing based snots because
those uh constructions they were based
on different assumptions and even those
that were based on elliptic curves they
we didn't care about which elliptic
curves because we can take anyone but
starting with pairing BS we started
constructing elliptic Curves in purpose
for snacks and for me the turning point
was this paper by Bono and Nissim it has
nothing to do with snars it is a dou
homomorphic encryption scheme that is
you can do any additions you want on the
cipher text and a single multiplication
on the cipher text but it wasn't
practical and this is because for the
decryption we needed to solve a discrete
logarithm problem so not practical but
fortunately uh so researchers like G gr
OSI and sahai between 2006 until 2
yeah yeah until 20110 they built on top
of this idea of w homomorphic encryption
because they said well it's not
practical but maybe in zkps we do not
need to do decryption we just need some
sort of a commitment then maybe we can
ditch decryption and we can have zero
knowledge TRS and they did this
but we didn't have implementation at
that point and the Turning Point
implementation wise was this paper by J
all they propos insightful constructions
for polinomial commitments and mixing
this with the pairing based papers
pairing based SNS papers well we started
having implementation and the first
implementation I'm aware of is this uh
paper called Pinocchio and when I looked
at the code it was proprietary still now
but they used uh B 256 curve from
another paper in 2010 binary all and it
was uh it had a 120 128bit security at
that time and to adct 5 so the term was
not Co to adct at that time but it just
mean for now like let's say perfor
performance
metric um a few months later there was
this paper parney where they implemented
BST side license Pinocchio with another
elliptic curve BN 254 from another paper
in 2010 and it has a 2 45 at that time
even if we didn't know know about what
is 2 C is
for um so same year so Bas kza and
others they uh implemented so
Pinocchio variant and they used a very
specific elliptic code I'm calling gmv
6183 it is due a to a paper to galberth
mck and Valena and the implementation is
still there today in libf it has a two
ad C 31 the two C notion was introduced
in this paper but it had a security 80
bit so they just so it is like for those
who know it's just like an MNT curve but
with a co-actor equal to four so that
they have like a a twisted Edward
form so uh next year pretty much the
same authors they uh proposed the BN the
famous BN 254 curve the curve that we
are using today in ethereum and what
they wanted is a two add to I mean bers
were used in pairing based cryog
but in SNS they wanted a two add so they
constructed this curve with two add 28
but my question is why didn't use the
curve from Pantry which has already a 45
to adicity and both on the prime field
the the the base field and the scalar
field and yeah I mean implementation
wise the one that we have today in
etherum is ugly especially when you
construct the tower and this one was
pretty much
simple um but yeah parings were used in
cryptography and so the researchers have
been working on the Crypt analysis of
paing but the Turning Point Crypt
analysis wise what this paper by Kim and
barbulescu so they found a new
complexity for solving the CR logarithm
problem over extension field but to give
proper credit it was this paper in 2016
same year by menes Saka and sink where
they anal analyzed the conclus the I
mean the impact of this Kim and bible
school paper on the choice of elliptic
cures and in their conclusion they
proposed using bls2 curve and for the
for the record bls2 there were curves
from 2001 and BM from 2005 and few
people cared about bls2 because of BN
but because of this paper we came back
to bls2 and I believe based on that fox
ad zika especially shenbo they proposed
the the the famous BLS 381 that we're
going to have now in Petra upgrade in
ethereum uh now if you want like
recursion you need two curves this is
what we call two cycle so you you need
two curves because to to express things
efficiently in a recursion you need the
curse to share some
parameters and it was this famous paper
uh scalable zero knowledge via cycles of
elliptic curves uh by basol that
proposed the first practical setting for
recursion and they devised the MNT 4289
and uh 298 and to MNT 6 298 uh it has
low security big to add City and they
also found another cycle but they
updated the paper only in 20120 on
ePrint 20 years lat uh six years later
I'm sorry but uh they shared the code
with the they shared the parameters with
Koda folks now Mina and they used Mina
used this at some point so it is a paper
from 2001 the construction of the
elliptic curve due to
Mia but just to give proper credits
again so it was a paper of 200 eight by
carabina and Tesco who established for
the first time that MNT 4 and MNT 6 form
are two
cycle uh and yeah so because of security
we need big parameters and it was or who
gave I think the biggest one so far uh
of size 992 so it is not practical I
mean it's it's slow but yeah for
research it's there but the two city is
small and it's very difficult to find a
higher security with higher uh adct MNT
Cycles but I think two weeks ago
Costello and corpal they proposed this
paper lollipops ofing friendly Li cures
and they solved the problem of higher to
ad for MNT cycles and the idea was
pretty much clever they took the MNT
Cycles I mean the problem with MNT
Cycles is like you need to solve this uh
pale generalized pale equation and to
increase your search space you need to
increase the discre some discriminant
and bigger the discriminant the harder
it is to find the curves let's put it
like this and what they did is like they
took mnts and they used some super
singular elliptic curves with some other
algorithm called Boker and it works but
it is still slow so not
practical and uh also Santos Costello
and narik they looked at cycles of Paran
friendly not elliptic curves but Curves
in general so and they proposed some mix
of elliptic curves ordinary super
singular and also some hyper elliptic
curves so it is as slow as MNT as far as
I can tell and also it is still early
research so implementation wise it's
going to be difficult to do like this a
billion varieties implementations
efficiently now if you want
just recursion but not infinite
recursion you just need to do a proof of
approve maybe just for aggregation you
need two chains so there is this famous
paper called ZXI they introduced this
curve called BLS 2377 which is used I
think in in Alo and in Soo others
blockchains and some Spin Six curve
in I think 2020 on print at least and
same year we proposed another so with or
another bw6 curve that was more
efficient and we generalized this to
some other to to any elliptic curve and
families but it was just research uh
implementation wise these two curves are
like bls2 and bw6 are the most efficient
nowadays for Two
Chains uh but it wasn't ZXI that that
introduced the notion of Two Chains it
was 5 years ago but hidden in some
appendix of the paper jeeto so they use
the same B250 54 cve from Pinocchio and
they built on top of it a bw6 curve
given the raise to the first
implementation of two chain uh yeah but
it was hidden in some
appendix now if you want to do recursion
without pairing paing friendly SNS you
just need cursion of some other snugs
that do not need pairings then you can
use plain Cycles so in the Halo paper
they introduced the twiddle twiddle
don't tdd d uh two cycle and they then
they replaced it with pasta which is
more efficient and it is used now in
Halo to implementation it is used in
folding schemes like in uh in the sonobi
implementation but it was a year AG a
year before that at least I've seen u a
two cycle in the zero knowledge uh
setting it was proposed by in this
website by uh Andrew postra and it is
the secp secq curve and he in his mail
he gave the the parameter so for me it
was the first one in the zero knowledge
setting but uh research wise it was in
2011 it was called amicable Pairs and
alot cycles and the the Halo paper sites
this one
actually but actually I was able to find
an implementation of plane two cycles
back to 2007 in a different context for
primality testing like when you test
test primes you can test them with
elliptic curves and it was FR Mor in his
implementation here where he was
discarding these plane Cycles because
they were bad for primality testing and
the same year the definition was uh
formalized in this paper by b m it's
called dual elliptic Prime so dual
elliptic primes amicable pairs alot
cycles and plane Cycles they are all the
same thing and I think two two two
months no this this summer I mean this
year um so Onan and others they looked
at elliptic curves that form cycle from
a mathematical point of view and they're
calling it elliptic over hpair so all of
these the same
thing um and if you want to mix
then uh snar based uh pairing based
snars and non pairing based snars you
can use uh hybrid two cycles so one of
them is proposed by di from zcash so
this is uh the
one uh and actually I was able to find
another implementation with BN 381 in
Mina protocol by uh Zach meckler but I
don't think it was used anywhere it was
just
experimental and then if you want
compatibility with etherum so Aztec
proposed the grin curve that is
compatible with b254 from
ethereum uh but actually I mean you can
take
any Prime order paing friendly elliptic
and by definition you can constract a
hybrid
cycle um and if you want to merge all of
these like you want to do a cycle and a
two chain so we calling it lollipops
like you can have a cycle and then a
stick it can be pairing friendly it can
be non pairing friendly it depends on
your use but together with Antonio sanso
from EF we proposed uh a way to build
families of like when you have a parent
friendly lipty curve and on top of it
you can have a uh a plane
cycle uh and then I think couple of days
after our paper oh Gil generalized our
idea with some other families of Curves
like KSS and then I think one week ago
on at list uh oror and Simo Mason they
proposed at even more General way to
construct those lollipops without fix I
mean with fixing the curve before we
couldn't fix the curve we had to to to
construct all the curves together but
they were able to construct it on for
example BLS 381 for
instance and yeah then lollipops they
found another way to do the lollipops
with all the curves being P friendly it
wasn't possible at that at this point
but they did it with super singular
elliptic Cur
which are defined ere extensions so make
things a bit more
slower yeah uh that's it for me so many
information but yeah thank
you thank you very much um here uh very
nice good overview covered a lot of
stuff there's a few questions I think
two one that kind of leads into the
other so maybe I can read out to you so
uh yeah I think one that was asked even
before the talk started so I think you
have a fan who's uh wondering what is
the future of curve based snarks
compared to Hash based snarks I was
expecting this question by the way I
mean yeah hash based snars they are fast
because you can constract them over
smaller Fields so you can speed up
things but I still believe that uh curve
based snarks they come with sness so
there is like a place for both and today
we see that for example for ZK VMS or ZK
EVMS they do a lot of Stark proving so
hash based SNS but then at the end of
the day they compose it or they wrap it
with a curve based SN so that they can
get ethereum compatibility one and they
can get sex sness which is like p s
small so I think I believe both are to
stay good uh then so do you think
recursive snark into Stark might present
an interest to be postquantum here snark
cannot be simulated by postquantum
computer how snark and start Stark
benches bench Mark okay so let me try to
understand the
question so I I I think yeah SNS if if
we're saying that SNS are based on
curves which is not really the case but
I understand it like this well if it is
based on curves it's not uh postquantum
uh Stars well if they are based on hash
hashes they are plausibly postquantum
composing both means that the protoc is
not post
Quantum um but yeah if you want post
Quantum resistance then then definitely
anything that is Hash based uh I mean
yeah we can also talk about
isogenes because they these are like uh
curves based these are postquantum but
I'm not aware of any isogen based snugs
yet and so I think then the last part of
the question how do they sort of
Benchmark against each other in terms of
efficiency so yeah yeah so it depends
really on what's what what Baseline we
benchmarking
against
um so it really depends but for example
if we if we are taking any um so so SNS
they are they work on over like big
fields defined by the elliptic curve so
if we Define the statement over this
field natively then it's competitive but
in stocks you can Define them over any
field and for example if you define them
over binary like Bas then you can do
things like kak faster so it's really
depends on the Baseline nice okay good
uh some more questions came in in the
meantime we have two minutes left so we
can go into it sure how important is
high two adicity uh can we get away
without it okay yeah so uh the two addic
city is um so so in elliptic C we're
working over this
subgroup uh of prime order and the two
adicity means just this order minus one
has to be divisible by a high power of
two and it just means fft friendliness
because the best way to implement f50s
is like radic 2 A50 and uh for big
circuits then you definitely need these
two adity for small circuits maybe you
can get away with smoothness like just
some some smooth uh uh uh integers
dividing like P minus one but yeah for
big circuit like for example I I work on
the linear ZK VM we work on big circuits
so yeah it's definitely a requirement
for us and why do you want to get away
without it I'm sorry why I'm just asking
my uh follow on like from my own
understanding why do you want to get
away without it like what problems does
it introduce yes so it's um it
introduces the fact that you need a
specific elliptic curve for example if
I'm talking about ethereum so ethereum
curve so the r minus one is divisible by
high power of two but the pus one is not
so if you want to do for example a
recursion of ethereum it wouldn't work
on the second layer yes of course uh
good then last question while we have 30
seconds left why is it crucial for
recursion to have two curves uh where
one is Prime and the other one is prime
one prime is the order of the other yes
so um we express the statement of
whatever we want to prove on the
subgroup or the of of the elliptic curve
and if we want to do a proof of a proof
we need to do the verification as a
statement but the verification uses
these pairings and pairings are defined
over a different field so if we want to
do pairings in the subgroup you need the
field of the pairing to match the field
of your subgroup so that computations
are native otherwise you need to emulate
non-native field arithmetic which is
quite costly I mean we do this but it's
quite costly but if you have native then
the number of constraints so your pro
generation will be way way faster good I
see there are more questions but we're
actually out of time maybe you can catch
them uh off off offline um but yeah
thank you very much I'm like thrilled
with the amount of questions uh great
thank you very much thank
you so um we have 4 minute now break
just to do a switch over but yeah we'll
be back in uh 4 minutes at at
5:30 uh see you in a few minutes
[Music]
hello and welcome back we're getting on
in the day but we're almost there so now
something that is quite close to my
heart a bit which is MPC and actually
making it uh publicly auditable so we
have task and uh can yeah we can welcome
the two speakers to give a pretty
introduction so yeah publicly auditable
NPC thank you very
[Music]
much okay hello everyone uh today I we'
like to talk about ZK MPC bringing
public audity into multiparty
computation yeah or MPC uh today I'm
excited to share our latest advantage uh
advancement in this field for
you okay this is the today's outline but
yeah let's start from introduction and
please give me a little bit time to yeah
for the team introduction Al yoi Inc is
a Japanese fintech company to helps and
entrepreneurs and businesses to grow uh
interesting uh uh increasing asset
liquidity with Innovative Financial
Solutions and we are doing R&D for uh
zkp and NPC to focus on secure and
efficient computation
so today I would like to talk about the
project which have received two ESP
grants from the is
foundation and this is our team member
uh this is Yus nak a researcher and
developer and I'm task and last he is
not here but we have Masa Masa uh
co-founder
CEO so uh let's go into the topic uh let
let me first introduce about the
importance of the secure computation uh
and MPC so secure computation in data
driven world is uh is really essential
it allows us to protect the sensitive uh
information such as health care and
financial and it enables useful analysis
without exposing information and
multiparty computation uh or MPC is a
key technology for this purpose uh so
yeah uh it enables multiple parties to
jointly comput functions while keeping
their inputs private and they only have
to share the final results so this to
ensure the secure
collaboration so uh let's think why uh
the third party verification for MPC is
essential uh especially the case we are
using dishonest majority protocols like
speeds uh when we are using uh dishonest
majority protocols uh participants like
Alice and Bob can verify them within
themselves that calculation results are
computed correctly uh however they
cannot directly prove uh the correctness
to the third party such as Charlie so in
this case Charlie will think can I trust
this
result uh yeah that's why uh I think
third party verification to NPC is very
uh
essential uh uh especially for use cases
like application to blockchain uh
finance and medical data
analytics so uh this will is the
overview for the rest of the uh
presentation uh firstly uh we will uh
show how
to uh introduce the public aity into
speed NPC protocol by introducing the
collaborative DK narks uh next we will
secure consistency of the secret input
which enable third party to verify the
input constraints using par and
commitment and next we will uh show our
enhancement of the bitwise support for
public auditable auditable speeds so
speeds is well suited for arithmetic
operations but not effective for uh
bitwise operation so we support uh
functions kind of such kind of uh
comparisons conditional branching and
debit composition and so on and this
will expand the range of possible
applications and as an application uh we
implemented the game master free
werewolf or sometimes called Mafia game
uh using MPC to Showcase how our
enhancement will make the MPC more
veratile to uh collaborative use
cases okay I I'll pass to
yusuke on next uh to achieve what we
introduced we need to understand the
backgrounds and issues uh in more depths
and we which we will
explain firstly let just began with the
uh NPC protocol Basics uh MPC uses the
techniques called secret sharing uh
which is uh data is splitted to some
shares and each party has uh it shares
one by one and there are some kind of
secret sharing like additive secret
sharing and shamia secret sharing and so
on let's consider the example of
addition X and Y is shared and the
addition of X Plus Y is uh can be
obtained by simply addition of the their
shares and however multiplication and
other more complicated operation needs
uh needs Communication in intermediate
steps yeah and speed space is one of the
well known NPC protocol proposed in
2011 and this is uh use this uses
additive secret sharing so it is
suitable for arithmetic operation like
addition and multiplication and so
on and there are two phases uh one is
pre-processing and the other is online
phase and the next we talk about the p
mppc uh publicly auditable NPC is the
most important Concept in our session
in order NPC uh the correctness of MPC
calculation can be verified by uh
participants however PMC uh impos MPC on
uh of third party
verification it was proposed in 2014
however the efficient implementation
does not exist at the
time however uh in 2021
the coopertive Z snacks which is the one
of efficient uh implementation of
publicly auditable NPC uh was proposed
by oir and
Bon the idea of cative snacks is to
prove uh to prove by m m
provs and the call KZ commitment uh KZ
commitment is a kind of polinomial
commitment which is used in DK snack and
pro and verifier uh communicate with uh
each other and
commitment uh Pro compute commitment and
send to proof to verifier and verifier
uh let check that the pairing of uh
specific
calculation and uh probative SNS uses
the
uh poal commitment uh in dkp like Marin
and pron and so
on and we focus on the mathematical
aspects of collaborative SN uh it's it
uh idea is very simple uh the pii is a
proof
uh proof generated by Shadow input and
Pi is the total
proof this techniques uses the linearity
of polinomial commitment and uh if we
generate uh
the proof uh each party then this is a
share of total
proof however if we want to uh use
collaborative ZK or PMP on blockchain uh
there are some issues to be
solved the figure shows that DK snacks
and NPC additive oriented and bitwise
oriented
NPC uh roughly speaking we want to
develop techniques in this Vision uh
which satisfies all three uh Legions
the first issue is the consistency of
secret inputs space uh in space uh there
are pre preprocessing phase and online
phase so we have to ensure that the
consistency of secret
inputs and this figure shows that
conventional NPC and the public
auditable
NPC and the second issue is require for
the general purpose
computations speed based NPC is suitable
for arithmetic operations however uh not
suitable for bitwise operations
so we have to uh we have to implement
such uh bitwise operations uh which is
efficient for Speed yeah and this uh
effect on constraint generation in zkp
uh because of restriction of finite FS
which can be used in
zkp and next uh we focus on the first
challenges the secure consistency of
secret
inputs in MPC uh in especially in space
uh the data input data uh is generated
by using auxiliary data uh created in
preprocessing phase so we have to
uh we have to be more cautious than
usual the committed data uh sorry we
solve this Problems by using
commitment
uh we we commit uh input data uh before
the input shares generated
so and at at
add constraint to dkp so we can verify
that the
uh data in preprocessing and online
phase and the proving phase is uh must
be
same and we choose p and commitment uh
to
implement
and there are some constraint uh with
implemented for example uh L constraint
and and so
on and we focus on second challenges
bitwise operation
support Rec call why uh bitwise
operation difficulty in space uh space
uses additive secret sharing so bit
decomposition and comparison uh such
operation uh will be more costly than uh
addition and
multiplication so if we using uh larger
finite Fields then more constraint needs
so we can't uh it is difficult to
implement it wise
operations uh implementation uh we added
especially uh equality zero test and
comparison test and and the B DEC
composition uh on speed spased
MPC and if we also implemented share
conversion protocol because Pedas and
commitment needs uh two different finite
fears and let's look the uh algorism
detail this shows the equality Zer
test let
that you have the data X of share of
data X and we want to uh calculate X is
zero or
not firstly we generate the random share
r with uh Associated bit with bwise
share and uh calculate X+ R and
publish uh this denote as C if x is zero
then R and C must be same so we use this
fact and culate uh AI uh this is bitwise
and output the
uh total an of all AI uh this means uh
one if x is zero and otherwise this
means zero
and
surprisingly uh
bitwise operation uh doesn't uh need for
additional
constraint uh for each
party even if
uh this can be considered as separation
of dkp prams and the uh NPC
prrams so we focus on each
Legions and next we want to show
application and demo
video we developed a wealth game Sorry
game master free wealth game uh this
flow chart shows that uh wh of game flow
chart well of game FL well game is a a
game uh the players are divided into two
teams one is Bard's team and the other
is we team and prayer uh whose Ro is
hidden and uh by
using specific L action and voting and
uh player aim
to victory for their
teams usually a we of game is necessary
for
necessary sorry game master is necessary
for we of game however we developed uh
game master free wealth game by our CK
MPC here is the list of we implemented
the protocol in the
DK R assignment Anonymous voting we of
attack Fortune ter check and victory
condition such computation is done by
NPC and uh we can check the con check
the correctness of such
actions let's pick up the L assignment
in
dkw uh players inputs the shuffle Matrix
uh by secret
shares and
then compute uh the ls by grouping
protocol and they generate uh
collaborative proof of Ro assignment
protocol then uh if the verification is
correct uh then they they are informed
uh their
RWS this is a demo video of our D MPC
uh this is four people
case
uh the Aris and Bob and charie and Dave
they register name and then set up began
uh right
away and the L assignment protocol is Le
is running and proof here is proof
Generation by MPC
see after the proof
generation uh the proof is
verified and uh they are uh Alice is
fortun ter uh both is weth and Charice
and Dave are
vages and the night phas uh they do uh
special
action AR Fortune teror uh Divine both
and over attack to
char and the discussion phase and voting
phase is
here ice and Bob and Dave uh both
then again the proof generation is
started
after the verification of the proof uh
Dae was
executed
here and finally the victory condition
check program uh is running
here also generating uh collaborative
proof after creating and verification
game is over weides win
here at TR uh we looking to the Future
Prospect of our zkm
PC if it is it becomes available on
blockchain
uh it it can be used as a more
it can be used as a sty NPC module on
blockchain uh with smart
contract
and it can be also applied to some
regions like machine learnings and
medical and financial data
uh such case uh
where multiple party needs to share
data and the DK MPC can
reduce the security risks and ensure
that the correctness of
calculation thank you for
lening thank you once again uh very nice
talk you covered many things uh we got
an overview of all of MPC uh background
on different protocols all that you've
implemented uh demo everything and
future I think it was really nice talk
thank you very much uh we have some
questions um maybe I will start at the
bottom so maybe I missed it but which
snark did you implement growth 16 or
something else uh ah sorry uh I I don't
WR gross 16 however uh gross 16 is also
implemented for our
zmpc like Marin and pron yeah so plon
Marlin and grow 16 yes very nice cool
uh did you implement everything from
scratch or did you use some existing
libraries uh in the part of our program
is
uh existing libraries uh for example the
crypto cryptographic uh
Primitives uh we uses aquax
library and uh the collaborate part uh
we refer to the original work however uh
in pre-processing phase of spe and the
bitwise
operations uh bitwise operation region
we we write uh from scratch nice
impressive cool and maybe one last
question for me is um where would you be
most excited to see this used what sort
of developer or application would you
really
love to see building this I think your
examples that you did with the games and
the demo was super nice but outside of
your team uh who would you love to see
using
it ah okay I'm really interested if this
is used in kind of uh medical case or to
make the machine learning model uh
together with a different organization
so if each organization has a different
secret data and they don't want to
reveal the data to each other but still
they can make learn the model to create
uh to create the model or to also do the
yeah um estimation from the model so I'm
really excited to combine this uh
technology with machine learning yeah
and you think it's efficient enough to
do um some machine learning in
MPC yes yes so if if you use MPC in
machine learning we the model itself can
be private or don't have to be re to
anyone yeah very nice cool well that's
all the questions we have um we'd like
to thank the speakers again for very
nice talk
um thank you thank you so we have a few
minutes six minutes before the LA next
and last session of the day um so yeah
we will be back in six minutes uh see
you soon thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome welcome back to the
last session of the day I think if you
have made it this far you're doing well
and I think the speakers will be very
glad that you've stayed I heard from a
bunch of speakers that are talking in
the kind of last sessions who's going to
stay so yeah you're very you're probably
the most appreciated audience members of
the day so thank you very much for
staying till the end uh we continue with
the theme of snarks I think this is now
the third in the row kind of um where we
look to uh building faster provs
basically and we will be given a very
nice overview from aam and bdan from the
consensus consensus pro team so I
welcome them to the stage and again scan
the QR code if you have questions up
vote each other and we will have a
wonderful Q&A at the end and there's no
one coming after so we can talk all
night thanks very much and welcome the
[Music]
speakers hi
everyone so today we're going to talk
about how to build provs uh this is a
joint talk with my colleague aam and um
yeah um the main purpose of the talk is
to see how we can use list polinomial
commitments and we're going to create
something based um on Lio and breakdown
which are two previous
Works uh so just a quick word about us
uh we're both cryptography researchers
uh at consensus uh and we're working in
the linear appr
team and since you here you probably
have been hearing all this time how to
make proofs how to make proofs we want
to make proofs um and this talk this
intermediate cryptography talk is about
how to actually uh do that
mathematically and how to construct a
proof system so we're going to dig into
some details some mathematical details
but we're going to do that hopefully in
a way that carries information across to
you
so just some motivation um at the high
level we're interested in how we can
move from a evm state to another one uh
there is the Eternal virtual machine
State transition um that basically
explains how that happens and what
happens in the layer two rollups is that
this state transition is being
arithmetization happened
properly and
why this is useful is that not all nodes
will have to perform the state
transition themselves they can just
verify the proof and since verification
um will be by design a very cheap
operation uh the overall system is going
to um to be quite
efficient and as I already um um as I
already um prepared you uh we're going
to look into how to construct such a
proof
system there will be two parts in our
talk the first part will be
uh the polinomial commitment scheme um
which we call Vortex and the second part
will be how to use this polinomial
commitment scheme some other Machinery
in order to um reason about the evm
execution so let's deep into
cryptography uh with polinomial
commitments um so basically like these
two parts um are the main building
blocks of how to build a
snark so po polinomial commitments uh
first you're going to have just a setup
algorithm and um at a very high level
it's just going to give you some public
parameters so public
parameters
and if you want to commit you're going
to use these public parameters you're
going to use some polinomial you want to
commit to a polinomial this poal will
have some bounded degree K and you're
going to Output some commitment
C and then we want to reason about this
polinomial about this commitment that we
just made and basically we're going to
look at a protocol that's interactive
between a pro and a verifier they both
have access to the polinomial to the
parameters to the commitment and in the
case of the prover also uh yeah also the
polinomial the verifier doesn't know the
polinomial only knows the commitment and
the prover basically attempts to prove
that P of X is indeed equal to
Y and this happens over multiple
interaction
rounds
um very high level the security
condition that we want to achieve is
that uh approver should not be able to
convince the verifier in the case that
he committed to something to some
polinomial that actually does not
evaluate to to the claimed
Y and we want to do this efficiently we
want to amortise our costs so basically
we're going to do something called batch
polinomial commitments in which instead
of committing to only one polinomial
we're going to commit to n of them uh
we're going to have we're going to claim
n evaluation n evaluations and basically
the proof is going to be a batched proof
a combined proof that all of these
polinomial evaluate
properly and also the verifier now knows
the evaluation um the claimed
evaluations and let's look into the math
that we use in order to build such a
thing um these are called the read
Solomon code and without getting into
the nitty-gritty um we going to use a
finite field fee F uh if you don't know
what a finite field is just imagine uh
uh integers modulos some prime
p and we are going to take some subset
of n elements A1 to a n from this final
field then encoding a polinomial so this
is about the codes encoding a polinomial
would just be evaluated the polinomial
at this end
points and in order for you to actually
in order for this encoding to actually
Express information about the
polinomial um you want that the degree
of p is actually smaller or equal than n
uh in order to be actually be able to
express it uniquely and in fact you want
to have this n is going to be much
higher you want to have redundant
information about the polinomial in
order to error
correct um and now let's look at the uh
what we uh where we took the the
starting point where we took inspiration
for our work uh which is the liero
breakdown protocol um these are two
separate schemes but um uh they have a
very common
structure so in this previous work the
setup algorithm would give you a hash
function as the public parameters and
then in order to commit to n pooms what
you're going to do is that you're going
to you're going to first compute the
encodings the read Solomon encodings of
the N
polinomial each row now corresponds to
an encoding you're going to construct
this Matrix and you're going to apply a
hash function on each column order to
get H1 then you apply the hash function
on the second column to get H2 and so on
and this is going to be your commitment
your commitment is this hashes of The
Columns of the encodings uh of your
polinomial so that's how you commit and
I put this here in case you forget it uh
now we are also interested in how do we
open how do we actually prove to the
verifier that uh our claimed evaluations
are
correct uh and in a secure way so
basically the verifier is going to send
the coin beta to the prover the is going
to compute this looks like a complicated
equation but actually it's not it's just
you have each row and each row gets
multiplied with the power of beta so
it's a linear combination of the rows
with this beta that comes from the
verifier this is a vector U send it to
the verifier the verifier now picks an
index that it wants to check it's only
going to be able to check one sends it
back and the prover replies to the
column of that specific index in this
case this is the first
one the verifier does two checks it
check that indeed when it applies the
hash function to the opened column to
the one that we just revealed it is
equal to the one in the commitment and
it checks that indeed if you compute the
linear combination of the betas with the
revealed columns then you're going to
get the I coordinate of
U and this protocol is going to ensure
that all the rows are indeed code
wordss but we want more than this we
want to actually make a proof about the
claimed evaluations of the polinomial
not just show that the rows are code
words and what we notice um in this work
is that if we interpolate this Vector
that is sent by the prover to obtain
some polinomial and then we also check
that this polinomial evaluated that X is
equal to the linear combinations of the
Y's if you do this additional check you
can actually ensure we can prove that
the polinomial evaluate
properly
and um
this proof can be very simple if you are
in the unique decoding regime which I'm
just going to talk about next um the
point is that if you want op if you want
optimal parameters the proof becomes
very complicated and I'm going to give
you just a flavor of why that is um so
basically when you're talking about
codes you you can consider two cases
there is the unique decoding which in
this case is exemplified by this radius
this is the target Vector that we want
to decode and this is a radius around it
and as you can see if you set it to this
length then there is only one code
word however you can also consider
relaxing this op this um this parameter
to be able to include multiple points
that are candidates for your
decoding and the proof for our
polinomial commitment schem becomes much
more complicated if you want the optimal
parameters if you want to have something
that's efficient in
practice so as I said the small one is
the unique coding regime there's only
one candidate and the yellow one is the
least one multiple
candidates um so the security guarantee
in the that we show in the listic coding
regime is that there will exist
polinomial polinomial a small degree
that evaluate correctly and this
commitments will have only a small
amount of coordinates that are different
from the target commitment that we are
decoding um and if you want more details
for the proof of security you can check
out a reprint uh and there's also P
thanks a lot I'm going to now now we're
going to move to the second part of the
talk where we're looking at how can we
use this pomal commitment to um in
conjunction with other things to reason
about the evm and uh I'm handing over
over to my colleague
aam thank you
ban uh
so uh let's go to the second part uh how
uh and here we are focusing what is
happening on Layer Two linear and how we
generate proof from evm execution via
such polinomial
commitment uh there are a lot of Step
until we can generate proof the first
step in this journey is arithmetization
and arithmetization for us is
mathematical modeling of evm by columns
and constraint between columns for
example if you want to prove that a
transaction had a valid signature first
you hash the signature so you have to
prove that the hash was correct so if I
want to here to show that hash of why I
start with column X and column X is a
kind of a describing your input X for
example you can consider the bite of the
X which are splitted in the cells of
these
columns then which uh with each steps of
the uh computation that is happening in
the hash uh this column you would have a
new column with new values in the cell
and so on until that you would arrive to
column Y which is your
output and there is constraint between
this column to say that uh how the
computation of the hash is going on so
by this arithmetization here we get
bunch of columns and constraint between
columns uh there are different uh
constraint uh uh for example it's just
uh example here there are more uh Lop
constraints or Lop query we Alo can
say which says uh column o is included
in column B uh or local constraint that
says okay if you have two columns then
uh the first row of these two columns
are
equal Global constraint which are very
important for us and uh they are more
about cell
uh the relation over the cells of or the
same column or even between several
columns uh I'm putting an example here
for Fibonacci sequence for uh for this
Fibonacci Sequence we know that for each
cell is in fact addition of two per
viiew cell so you write the constraint
like
this for this uh and we call this one
Trace uh trace of execution or
Fibonacci okay if you want to verify
this Con constraint as a verifier
definitely you don't want to do it like
this because it's too many effort
especially Global constraint because
they are over the cells and you have to
check a lot of uh relation between
columns and cells so and that's where uh
polinomial commitment comes to
rescue we write each column as a
polinomial uh we interpret the column as
a
polinomial for example you can say that
okay the values in the columns you can
see them as the coefficient of a
polinomial and by this the constraint
would be translated as a relation
between pols and from here you can apply
polinomial commitment I want you I
remind you that polinomial commitment
can do two task for you which are very
simple but very important one task was
it can commit and uh by a short
commitment and you can use the
commitment uh to open to request the
evaluation of the
polinomial uh another interesting uh
property of the polinomial is that why
we are interested in polinomial and why
we are going from columns to polinomial
is thanks to this Lemma Schwarz zma and
it says that if you have a relation for
a polinomial between polinomial
commitments you don't need to check the
relation for each ex you just take a
random point from the domain and if the
relation over the random Point Alpha
satisfied then you know that it was
satisfied for every ex this would
simplify everything and that's why we
are interested in polinomial because by
this verifier uh task is very easy it
just needs to take a random point and
then verify the polinomial and con
string over this
random uh so by this so we can get now
uh pols a bunch of polinomial and
constraints we are very close to get the
proof but we are not still there and the
reason is that this constraint are not
the constraint that uh I
want uh the constraint that we are
interested in are Global constraint why
Global constraint because uh thanks to
this short Zer Lemo uh you can verify
them easily uh Global constraint are
between cells so you don't need to check
them between cells you use uh short zipo
over global constraint and you just
check in a random point so we are
interested to kind of reduce this
constraint every constraint that you
have for example look up queries
permutation queries and a lot of queries
that may happen in during
arithmetization we want to replace them
with global constraint because from
there we have we can have a simple
verification uh via short Z
LMO to do this to go uh to get Global
constraint we need uh
piop but what is
piop piop stands for polinomial
interactive Oracle
proof uh it's a idealize ideal modeling
of a protocol between prer and
verifier
uh you have a third party between prover
and verifier uh this uh handsome guy uh
that we call it
Oracle Oracle is honest and can answer
any question so prover and verifier
start their interactions and they use
this uh Oracle to help them to reduce
their constraint uh to Global
constraint and uh there is a
theorum that says that polinomial
commitment in such
construction uh resemble to an oracle
because Oracle does not exist uh such
guy does not exist unfortunately so we
have to replace it with something real
and there is a theorem that says that
polinomial commitment is a good
candidate and you can replace it with
this guy to help you to reduce your
polinomial to constraint to normal to
Global and now we are fine so we use
piop we reduce everything to the global
constraint and we can use a polinomial
commitment for this but we cannot use
our Vortex and the reason is that our
Vortex is not a standard polinomial
commitment that and the theorem is not
true uh it's not a good candidate for
Oracle
uh why it's not good candidate it's
because of this uh property least
property uh why it makes problem why it
cannot work with
piop and the reason is that in piop you
have rounds of interactions between
prover and verifier and uh in fact due
to this Leist property polinomial has a
lot of choices in different rounds and
he can do kind of mix match attack
between different rounds and different
polinomial from the
list uh but we have a trick for this we
uh can prevent uh in in fact we use a
trick to force uh which we call it comit
separately and open collectively and by
this uh I don't go to the details
theoretical details but by this
trick we are uh we are able to force the
prover in fact to open uh all the uh
polinomial commitments at the same
position over the D skill let's say uh
so for the first round maybe he has
choices but for the other rounds he
doesn't have choice and he has to stick
to the First
Choice uh so this would solve the
problem of list but still Vortex is not
good one more step and why it's not uh
good it's now because this nice property
I call it nice because it's batching but
batching uh uh it's not an uh General
batching uh as you see in Vortex the
batching is just batching of all the
polinomial over the same
point uh and in real application piop
applications when you applied your P op
in fact you are in the general case that
you have many polinomial many uh points
so this kind of batching even though
it's nice but it's more fantasy and it's
not applicable
here uh but we also find another
theoretical trick to solve this
problem still I would not go to the
theory just uh uh the general view is
that we come back uh to the step that we
designed our piop uh and we kind of
modify it to be able to use a batching
over the same point and the way that we
modify it uh is just uh first the uh
convert uh can speak freely and at the
end we apply uh a kind of reduction via
Oracle over the same point and from here
now Vortex is applicable we can replace
our Vortex with Oracle and we are done
finally we have our first
proof and here is just an example of the
parameters if you are interested thank
you very much
thank you very much
uh I love the dynamic between the two of
you explaining the different sites it
was cool uh we have some questions and
uh also some that I had it sorry I also
introduced you wrong I said you're from
the prover team of consensus and then I
was like consensus doesn't do proves so
from the Linea team and I guess that
became clear immediately but yeah so one
of the first questions was uh is this
The Vortex that line
uses uh yes uh this is the first proof
uh that's why I mentioned that finally
we have our first proof this is the
first proof that we generate after there
are a lot of more layers that will come
to aggregate a uh the these initial
proofs and finally a final proof to be
compatible with uh ethereum uh but this
is yes this is the first proof that we
generate in
linear and the classic uh any benchmarks
how fast is it uh Benchmark was uh
because uh as I said this is the first
proof so we have several kind of
recursion and uh our estimation is that
uh you need for 100 bits of you security
you need 15 millions of constraint uh
inside of for the verifier of Vortex
inside of
plun and uh comparing to breakdown and
the liero that are in unique decoding uh
this is four times fast the not faster
but the size of the proof is four times
smaller nice so I think this uh question
comes up or well this might answer the
next question in part at least so what
are the advantages disadvantages of
Vortex compared to other polinomial
commitment schemes so in terms of pro
time proof size you mentioned with proof
size already
but uh yes I mentioned about proof size
size that uh is a uh faster than
breakdown smaller than breakdown four
times due to due to the least uh
commitment property and regarding the pr
time uh uh
um both are uh good I mean it's as good
as breakdown but it's also I can compare
it with a fry for example because uh
Vortex it's very important property that
it's doesn't need thrusted setup it's
like fry and uh comparing to fry the pr
is
faster yeah good so a last question uh
is batching over the same point does it
impact the security uh that's why we
went all through this uh uh modifying
poop and modifying uh distri of uh
commit uh um separately open
collectively all of this was for the SEC
proof of security so the paper in fact
analyz the security that okay it's not a
standard commitment so how can we use it
uh
securely nice I see maybe one more
question came in as we've two minutes
left for questions maybe we can uh
scroll and see I actually left my uh
phone
okay never mind what question would you
love to
hear pick your own question
what field do you
use uh uh in fact the only property that
we need is because you uh uh we use fft
so the only property that we need is to
add city which means that the order of
if your field is a q the prime that we
are using Q minus y should be a big
factor of uh two two uh so if you have
this property it's enough for us after
uh because we also have used it's a ltis
for the hash for hashing of the columns
uh so we may for optimization can we
have uh more choices in distance but
already this the this fact that we just
need to add city is it would give us a
big Choice nice good and thank you to
whoever up folded the question so we
could read it collaboration ated its fin
so let's thank the speakers once again
um thank you and yeah catch them if you
want to know about L's Prov thank you
very much by uh and that's it I think
that is the first day over on stage
three so thank you very much for being
here and for listening and staying till
the end uh we're very much appreciative
of it h see you around tomorrow good
evening
[Music]
[Applause]
h
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]